Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Also, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Ohje, Kabel verwirrt, es ist fack, und Teppich verschoben unterm Tisch, meine Güte hier,
generell hier schaut es wieder aus, ich muss unbedingt mal wieder meine Kartons ordentlich
einsortieren, ganze Technik-Krams was hier rumfliegt, egal ihr müsst das ja nicht sehen,
ist das nicht so wild, moin Leute, Pock, Pock, Pock, Pock, Pock, Pock, ihr werdet es nicht
glauben, es ist 18.46 Uhr, ich bin müde wie Sau, ich habe gerade drei Stunden oder länger,
vier Stunden draußen die Terrasse mitgemacht mit einem Netz und ein paar Kabel, also Stahlseile
sind das, dass die Katz auf die Terrasse kann und nicht abhaut, wenn die abhaut, dann ist
sie auf der Straße und wird umgefahren und das muss ja nicht sein, Chico ist so verplant,
die kennt nur die Wohnung, wenn die draußen ist, die springt vor das Auto und weiß nicht,
was ihr passiert.
Poga, ja richtig, Bedgetime, aber es ist jetzt noch zwei Stunden Zeit bis, nee warte mal,
vier Stunden ungefähr Zeit bis Bedgetime, das dauert noch ein bisschen, deswegen gucken
wir uns heute mal Arch, by the way, eine Manjaro Arch Distributions Alternative an, weil ja,
ihr wisst ja, ich benutze Manjaro schon eine ganze Weile, also Manjaro Linux und das ist
ja bei einigen Leuten in Ungnade gefallen in den letzten 1-2 Jahren, bei mir ehrlich
gesagt nicht so, was mir auf den Keks geht, ist, dass es keine Architekt Version mehr
gibt und man minimal installieren kann, das finde ich tatsächlich sehr blöde und mal
gucken, man schadet ja nichts, wenn man sich mal ein paar andere Sachen anschaut und die
Kirby Musik ist mir tatsächlich zu happy gerade, ja, aber jetzt warten wir erst mal
bis Twitch richtig mitbekommen hat, dass der Stream on ist, ja, macht's, deswegen ist
das wahrscheinlich mehr Arch als Manjaro, Arch by the way, deswegen dachte ich mir,
das muss ich auch gleich mal nen Titel schreiben, by the way, dass ich Arch benutze, by the
way, Gravuzzi, danke schön für 3 Monate Prime Subscription, einfach Arch mit Arch
Fire Script installieren, ja, kann man alles machen, why not, ja, ich nutze nur Betriebssysteme
mit Teams-Integration, was ist denn ein Betriebssystem mit Teams-Integration oder besser gesagt,
wofür bekommst du kein Teams, es gibt doch Teams, gibt es doch für alles, was Windows
11 hat, hat Windows 11 eine spezielle, super, advanced Teams-Integration oder wie, ne, vorinstalliert
brauche ich das ja beim besten Willen nicht, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, das kommt mir nicht in
die Tüte, aber ich werde eh nicht so schnell auf Windows 11 upgraden, wisst ihr was der
größte Abfakt für mich ist, in Windows 11, dass man jetzt nicht mehr sagen kann, ich
weiß gar nicht wo das ist, wo ist denn, bin ich jetzt blöd, wo ist denn das Grouping,
ich finde es jetzt schon nicht, also man kann das Grouping nicht mehr abschalten, die Zimmern
Leute, hier Combine Taskbar Buttons, das ist das, das gibt es nicht mehr, guck, in Windows
11 gibt es nur noch das und ich hasse das, ich hasse es extrem, ich mag das, ich will,
wenn ich schon so einen Müll wie ne Taskleiste hab, dann will ich das so haben, dass ich
den Kram sehe, ich brauch keine Taskleiste, ihr wisst, ich verwende hier mein Manjaro
mit I3 die ganze Zeit, das hat auch keine Taskleiste, aber da hab ich ganz viele verschiedene
Desktop, aber wenn ich schon so was wie ne Taskleiste habe, dann will ich wenigstens
auch was damit anfangen können und nicht doppelt und dreifach hier durch, weil wenn
ich jetzt hier dreimal, dreimal, viermal Chrome auf hab und hab das Windows Default, da blickst
es nicht mehr durch, das ist totaler Crap, vor allem selbst wenn jetzt jemand sagt, nö
ich mag das anders lieber, ist doch egal, warum machen die nicht einfach eine Option
rein, ja natürlich, ich mein, es muss ja einen Grund haben, warum ich 32 Gramm hab
seit ein paar Jahren, das hier kommt dir auch nicht in die Tüte, was ist das denn für
Crap, Rentner, wollt ihr Glasfaser, das kostet dann 5 Euro mehr oder kommen dann die Rentner
an und sagen, was ist das für neu modische Scheiß, da kann ich mich dran erinnern, das
braucht doch keiner und dann soll ich auch noch mehr für den, für bezahle, nee, nee,
nee, lass mal gut, ja das sagen die Rentner aber wirklich und nicht nur die Rentner, auch
die ganzen Boomer Leute sagen das, eine Taskleiste pro offenen Programm, naja so ähnlich, so
ähnlich mach ichs ja schon unter I3, ich hab ersten Desktop Fullscreen Browser, zweiten
Desktop Fullscreen Terminal, dritten Desktop Fullscreen Visual Studio Code, vierten Desktop
Fullscreen IDE, so fertig, mehr brauch ich nicht, einfach KDE und für alles ist eine
Option, ja bei KDE ist es mir fast schon zu viel, also geht halt um das hier, die Playlist
kann sich nicht so ganz entscheiden mit der Lautstärke oder, Linux vom Scratch geht am
schnellsten natürlich, wisst ihr was mich immer noch ein bisschen schockt, dass Unraid
tatsächlich Slackware ist, also heute gucken wir uns mal das da an und was auch immer die
mit ihren Astronauten die ganze Zeit wollen, gut wahrscheinlich hieß nicht eines der Space
Shuttle Endeavor, ach ich glaub schon oder, der junge Inspector Morse, achja alles klar,
was auch immer Space Shuttle, ja deswegen haben sie es mit dem Astronaut hier wahrscheinlich
keine Ahnung, ja und was die halt sagen ist, dass sie, Moment haben die standardmäßig
einen Dark Theme, nee, MonkaS, alter Sekunde, ich bin blind, ich bin blind, ich fände das
immer mit dem Einschaltknopf, weißt du was das besondere an Endeavor ist, naja, also
wenn du jetzt da drauf anspielst, das was du meinst, weiß ich wahrscheinlich nicht,
der Unterschied zu Manjaro ist, dass sie die offiziellen Art Stripos, achso ich dachte
du weißt das, also die sagen unter anderem sie verwenden halt, also meiner persönlichen
Ansicht nach ist das ein Vorteil, ja, sie verwenden die offiziellen Arch Repos und nicht
wie Manjaro so ein zwei Wochen versetztes Repo und ansonsten, tja mal gucken was sagen
sie denn, Friendly Community, was ist das für ein Stream, Charity Stream, Building Linux
und Firefox, Leute ich habe mal versucht Chrome selbst zu kompilieren, ich hab's irgendwann
sein lassen, das braucht auch gefühlt 120 Gigabyte RAM, 5 Terabyte Festplatte und das
halbe Internet als Dependency, da hat er ganz schön was zu tun, sag mal, die Playlist sackt
von der Lautstärke, die sind mal unterschiedlich und Playlist, Playlist mit nicht richtig abgemischt
der Sound-Lautstärke ist doof, was, das ist keine verkackte Musik, hast du mal Alpine
Linux getestet, ja, ich hab Alpine schon öfters verwendet als Grundlage für irgendwelche
Container-Images, aber ich glaube nicht, dass man Alpine, dass irgendjemand Alpine für
irgendwas anderes verwendet, also hab ich zumindest noch nie gesehen, ich kenn keine Alpine auf
dem Desktop verwendet oder sowas, geht das überhaupt und warum nicht, dann ist man aber
äußerst minimalistisch unterwegs, ja und ansonsten, was sagen die dann sonst noch so,
Daniel Lull, 32 Monate Alter, das ist ja mal richtig, danke schön für die 32 Monate
Subscription hier, richtig nice, so, dann erzählen sie halt so sagen, Friendly Community, gut,
da kann man sich drüber streiten, ich muss sagen, ich fand jetzt die Manjaro Community
auch gar nicht so schlimm, Latest Features, gut, sie haben halt keine Repost dazwischen,
bla bla bla, was haben sie sonst wie, eine der Vorteile ist wohl tatsächlich, es gibt
eine Minimal-Installation im Vergleich zu Manjaro, wie gesagt, man kann sich auch einfach
Arch Linux, dann kann man nämlich richtig echt Arch, by the way, usen, aber was wir
heute mal ausprobieren werden ist, wir gucken uns mal die Minimal-Installation an, müsste
es eine geben, aber danach gucken wir uns mal die unterschiedlichen vorkonfigurierten
Flavors an und ihr wisst ja, ich bin ein, wo ist es denn jetzt, ich bin ein i3 Benutzer
und die haben wohl ein fertiges i3 Flavor, wenn ich es jetzt finden würde, wo ist es
denn, ich hab, ich hab das vorhin gefunden, da hatten die auf ihrer Webseite alle möglichen
Flavors aufgelistet, was sie so haben, wenn ich das, aber eben finde ich das nicht mehr,
ach hier, doch, direkt auf der Startseite ist es jetzt, ich hab's wieder, Our Flavors,
so, es gibt es als XFCE, als Mate, als Cinnamon, als Gnome, die Webseite ist ein bisschen
kaputt, siehste Leute, deswegen ist sowas wie Endless-Crawl-Müll, Batschi hab ich noch
nie verwendet, hat das mal jemand von euch verwendet, Batschi Desktop, Plasma, also Moment,
ist Plasma nicht KDE, Plasma ist doch KDE, oder, LXQT, QT, LXDE i3, jetzt wird's la,
Openbox, jetzt wird's aber langsam abgedreht, ja, also wir probieren nachher auf jeden
Fall mal den, das i3-Flavor aus, mal gucken, ob das was taugt, da bin ich mal gespannt,
ja, schauen wir uns mal an, mal schauen, bin mal gespannt, ich mein, nee, manjaro gab
es nur den Architekt, es gibt kein anderes Minimal, guck mal manjaro, Flavors, ich weiß
gar nicht wie der Kram da heißt bei denen, ne, i3, manjaro, die haben XFCE, die haben
glaub Gnome, ne, XFCE, Plasma und Gnome, was anderes haben die nicht mehr offiziell,
früher hatten die noch Architekt, aber das gibt's auch nicht mehr, also, ich find das
ein bisschen doof, schau mal unter manjaro, ja Moment, Minimal heißt in dem Fall wahrscheinlich
einfach nur, ja, das heißt Minimal XFCE Desktop ohne extra Zusatzsoftware, das ist aber nicht
mit Architekt zu vergleichen, wo du quasi ein absolut Minimal-System kriegst mit Commandline
und sogar X selbst installieren musst, gibt es das französische Linux, keine Ahnung,
ich hab mich mit französischen Linux noch nicht so beschäftigt, was geht mit der Playlist
ab, ne, das ist nix, wir machen lieber Mario Kart oder irgendwie was, oder Yoshi Playlist,
ne, das ist mir zu einschläfern, da penn ich jetzt wirklich ein, das hatten wir das letzte
Mal erst, wir machen einfach die Mario Kart Playlist, die geht in der Regel immer, Baguette
US, ey was geht ab, wie gesagt heute gucken wir uns mal Endeavor OS an, also wem ihr diesem
Stream zu verdanken habt, ist irgendeinem komischen Reddit-Post, den ich vorhin gelesen
hab, unter einem anderen Post, also man sieht ja auf seiner Reddit-Startseite immer neueste
Themen der subscribten Subreddits, manchmal siehst du dann unten drunter noch dieses Thema
irgendwie an Ähnlichkeiten zu oder sowas, und da war das drinne und das war eigentlich
ein Topic, da ging es darum, irgendwie 21 Gründe warum derjenige kein Manjaro mehr verwendet
und irgendeiner hat dann drunter geschrieben, ja ich bin jetzt auf Endeavor OS geswitcht
oder so, da hab ich mir das mal angeguckt, hab gedacht, ja, das könnte man tatsächlich
auch mal ausprobieren, mal gucken, wir könnten ja auch mal dieses russische Linux ausprobieren,
die haben ja ein eigenes, ich hab vergessen wie es heißt, hat jemand aus dem Kopf noch
den Namen von diesem russischen Linux, hatten doch einen, war das Astralinux, astralinux.ru,
nein das war das nicht, die Redstar OS sind die Koreaner, ein Arbeitskollege von dir benutzt
Endeavor, findest besser als Manjaro, also das einzige was ich aktuell als Vorteil gesehen
hab ist eben, dass sie die offiziellen Arch Repos verwenden, was ja schon mal nicht verkehrt
ist, so, latest, latest release, Installation, mal gucken, wir können auch gleich mal gucken
wie gut das offizielle Wiki ist, schau mal her, wo gibt's Download, was für ein Ding,
was wollen die hier alles mit Calamares, you can download over here, oh guck mal, man kann
direkt von ShitHub herunterladen, Linux Pizza, das ist das richtige für mich, Linux Pizza
aus Schweden, nee wir laden von ShitHub runter, hab ich auch noch Platz auf der Platte, Sekunde,
also, Ubuntu on Linux, recently added, ist mir neu, dass ich das recently geedit hab,
aber anscheinend hab ich es recently, recently added, du bist nur vorbeigekommen, sagst du
immer nicht, man kann von dem her aus gucken, welchen
Quasi wie eBay nur ohne Auktionen
Es kommt natürlich auf den Händler an aber auf der anderen seite und da muss ich sagen da muss ich lithium recht geben ich hatte bisher
zweimal probleme mit einem Händler auf AliExpress und beide male hat AliExpress
Quasi in meinem zu meinen gunsten entschieden und das obwohl ich nicht reagiert habe
also
Da ich habe bisher nur gute erfahrung mit AliExpress gemacht der einzige wirklich große nachteil von AliExpress ist
Wenn du nicht aufpasst dass der versandt
Ewig dauert
Also also richtig lange wenn du die falschen optionen nimmt und beim falschen Händler bestellt
Also beim zoll ist bei mir noch nie was hängen geblieben
AliExpress China Chinesen Zeug welches wäre die falsche option
Kann ich dir zeigen ok zum beispiel wir nehmen wir nehmen jetzt mal einfach irgendwas
So das da das wollte ich schon immer mache ich habe keine ahnung was das überhaupt ist ein mini smart switch
So das ist zum beispiel schon mal wahrscheinlich nicht die richtige option
29 April aber mir geht nicht du brauchst
Das ist neu seit wann sieht das bei AliExpress so aus
Früher hatten die dinger also von spanien bis germany das ist schon mal deutlich besser
Weil da weißt du du musst auf jeden fall kann du bekommst definitiv keine probleme mit dem zoll wenn das von spanien kommt
Warum ist das denn jetzt anders früher hießen die sachen wie AliExpress standard
Eu priority line und so was und da musstest du immer eu priority line nehmen aber was ist das denn hier
Also generell ehrlich gesagt das hier die standard kostenfreie liefung
kostenfreie liefung china bis germany 29 april das ist schon mal müll das ist eineinhalb monate also ich würde das hier nehmen
spanien bis deutschland
So so was in der richtung weil spanien nach deutschland ist versandt in der eu und das ist was sie garantiert
Kein zoll vorausgesetzt das zeug ist natürlich mit das gut das muss natürlich in spanien einmal durch den zoll
Aber da hat bestimmt AliExpress mittel und wege das ordentlich korrekt zu machen
kappa
Zumindest gibt es dann die probleme
Also ich musste noch nie
Ihr könnt ja mal eure eurer erfahrungen berichten chat ich musste noch nie
Wenn ich sachen in china bestellt habe zum zoll noch nie
Wo ich bisher nahezu immer zum zoll musste ist als ich aus den usa bestellt habe
Also die konas haben es nicht drauf mit zoll dokumenten und allem die kriegen das nicht in usa
bisher
immer ich sag jetzt nicht
Jede bestellung aber mir fällt keine ein wo ich nicht zum zoll musste deswegen also ich glaube immer
Also usa hat es nie hinbekommen
Was denn das für das ist in mario kart track
Also uns aus china habe ich noch nie probleme gehabt
Das schlimmste war das
Das schlimmste war das letzte mal als sie in usa bestellt habe dann habe ich dem händler gesagt bitte kümmere dich um
versand und zoll
Das bietet dhl an dhl bietet quasi international an dass sie das verzollen händeln und dann kam das in leipzig an
Und das war ich habe express bestellt
Das das ging drei wochen ich habe es euch ja damals erzählt es ging drei wochen irgendwie
Hin und her und die haben sie in leipzig nicht auf die reihe bekommen von dhl
Da habe ich ja ich habe die dokumenten hoch geladen nein sie brauchen noch dokumenten aber die habe ich auch schon längst hoch geladen aber das
sehe ich jetzt nicht
Da hat mich irgendeine frau vom leipziger
Dhl angerufen und meinte irgendwas mit die dokumenten fehlen noch
Und dann habe ich sie gefragt habe ich gesagt ja was genau
Fällt dann jetzt ich habe die sache doch hochgeladen und dann meinte sie zu mir aber das dürfen sie mich jetzt nicht fragen
Da dachte ich mir auch noch, weil du mich veräppeln oder was ihr kriegt irgendwie 40 euro oder so insgesamt obendrauf dass ich euch um die verzollung kümmern
Also das das war wirklich ganz ganz beschissen
Alter
Ja das wie gesagt die amis haben das nicht drauf benutzt du iphone oder samsung
Wait a minute
Es gibt durchaus noch mehr optionen außer iphone und samsung
Aber ich habe ein iphone das ist korrekt
Aber nicht nur also ich habe also smart phones tatsächlich sind nur iphone
aktuell habe ich hier
Weil alles hier gesamt der haushalt haben wir ich habe ein iphone 11
Dann haben
Habe ich noch ein altes
Sechser ist das glaube ich da ein se 1 und noch ein iphone 11 war wie gesagt nicht alles für mich und
An tablet sieht es aber schon wieder anders aus tablets sind zwar zum größten teil ipads
Aber wir haben ja auch noch einige android geräte gerade im unteren preissegment und wenn es ums automatisieren geht
Sind die feier tv äh nicht die feier tv die die feier tablets ganz gut wenn man die end
amazonifiziert
Ja ich habe ein iphone 11 vor zwei monaten werkzeug war bestellt war schneller als meine
Ok nicht schlecht wie gesagt bei mir sind bestellungen aus den usa prinzipiell gibt es da probleme mit dem zoll
Das ist schon fertig
Deshalb hast du dich für apple entschieden als smart phone weil ich es nicht selbst bezahlen muss
Das ist der einzige grund
Und seitdem bin ich damit so warm geworden dass ich mir privat jetzt auch ein ipad noch ein iphone gekauft habe
Der eigentliche grund warum ich warum ich ein iphone habe ist weil ich quasi von dort von der firma wo ich arbeite
Eins bekomme immer regelmäßig in aktuellen aktuelles modell und dann habe ich mich jetzt halt
Da nie beschwert darüber und hat mich jetzt dran gewöhnt
Korrekt
Willst du beim iphone bleiben hast du den gedanken zu wechseln nee
Ich wechsle nicht weil ich muss das iphone nicht bezahlen kann man ein feier tablet mit android versehen
Feiertablet ist android allerdings kein sonderlich aktuelles
Du kannst darauf aber auch den google store machen oder apk sideload das kein problem
Ich würde dir aber empfehlen dass zu etwas amazon zu die plauden
Also nicht die lauden die plauden also weniger pp fett machen
Dass du auch die ganze amazon werbung los wirst und sowas
Ja es ist mega für den arsch aus den usr was zu bestellen
Ich benutze es firmentechnisch weil das von der firma ist
So gut was macht die iso die ist fertig
downloads
Endeavor atlantis war atlan war das nicht auch ein space shuttle
Die sind aber ganz schön
nasa nasa fans
Wie hieß das gab es nicht mal mal frage an die weeps unter uns
gab es gab es nicht mal nasa chan oder sowas
Ach nee das war earth chan oder
Mit nasa na das war nicht das das das war nicht das war nicht das war nicht nasa es war earth chan nicht nasa
Ich frage mich nicht wie ich da gerade draufkomme. So also jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Jetzt haben wir uns auch mit aliexpress ein bisschen auseinander gesetzt jetzt äh probieren wir das mal aus
Wir legen mal eine vm an zack gibt noch questions im chat
Und zwar was für ein linux findest du am besten wenn man das erste mal linux sieht
Und zwar was für ein linux findest du am besten wenn man das erste mal linux versuchen wird ganz ehrlich
Da würde ich gar keine großartigen spiritien machen ich würde auf jeden fall nicht arch by the way
Usen als erstes gibt jetzt bestimmt leute die sagen nein max arch linux bestes einstieg linux oder sonst was
Ich würde auch nicht ubuntu ich würde tatsächlich mint verwenden mint ist so das verbreitetste
und und
Man kann sich jetzt drüber streiten ob es wirklich das einsteiger freundlich ist aber der vorteil von mint ist
Es ist verbreitet und gerade bei einsteigern verbreitet und du hast auch sehr viele tutorials helfen
Sei es forum reddit sonst was also mint würde ich fast sagen ist zum einstieg echt das was ich empfehlen würde
Was ich empfehlen würde ja das finde ich ist übrigens das täuscht oder das das ist nee nee das täuscht nicht
Also es ist schon so das sind wenn man windows ein bisschen ähnlich ist gerade hier unten mit der taskleiste sowas
Aber ich finde das ist das täuscht ist das falsche wort was will ich denn jetzt eigentlich sagen
Das trügt dass der schein trügt deswegen finde ich es auch gar nicht so gut wenn linux distributionen versuchen
Möglichst windows ähnlich zu sein weil dann hast du die noobs die meinen ach das ist doch wie windows ich weiß doch wie das geht
Und spätestens wenn sie das erste mal auf die kommando zeile müssen machen sie den hier
Und sagen so alter lul linux rückständig kommando zeile wer muss denn auf die kommando zeile und wisst ihr wem wir es verdanken haben
Dass die leute angst vor der kommando zeile haben wir haben es dem hier zu verdanken
Diesem ding hier haben wir das zu verdanken dass die leute angst vor der kommando zeile haben
Diesem drecksteil von windows also das ist auf mehreren ebenden absoluter bodensatz
Erstens das terminal der terminal emulator hier dieses fenster da ist mega beschissen
Und das nächste ist die die kommando zeile die shell ist mega mega beschissen was ist die steuerung was sind die die die die steigerung davon
Also die beschissenste shell so überhaupt so und deswegen haben die leute angst davor
Cmd alter piss dich ja das ist echt echt so cmd kann man bloß sagen
Piss dich also
Mehr kann man zu cmd nicht sagen giga beschissen genau
Und noobs müssen gerade unter linux schon ab und zu mal auf die kommando zeile
Kann ja kann ja alles mögliche sein ich meine manchmal unter windows musst du in die registry und kannst du alles verkacken
Aber unter linux musst du manchmal in die kommando zeile
Was weiß ich irgendwelche scripts ausführen
Irgendwas was weiß ich vom vom drucker wenn einrichten bis zu keine ahnung es fällt mir jetzt kein gutes beispiel ein ehrlich gesagt
Aber es gibt genug sachen wo du unter linux das am besten und am schnellsten einfach mit drei vier zeilen auf der mit drei vier sachen auf der kommando zeile erledigt
Wo ich gar nicht wissen wüsste wo man klicken muss
Also ich komme beispielsweise ich benutze nie den grafischen das grafische update tool ich mache selbst unter ubuntu server ich mache immer update upgrade
Wozu soll ich irgendwas gooey mäßiges verwenden ich meine selbst unter linux desktop
Ja und sobald was nicht geht und in den config datei muss bruchst du halt auf die kommando zeile
Du kommst unter linux auch als einsteiger früher oder später mal in die situation dass du auf der kommando zeile was machen musst
Und das gute ist eben wenn es es gar nicht so aussieht wie windows dass die leute da nicht herangehen mit es ist windows und weniger angst vor der kommando zeile haben
Weil du kannst linux nicht benutzen sag mal mal main os technisch wenn du komplett schiss vor der kommando zeile hast das das klappt nicht richtig
So jetzt haben wir aber den kram runter geladen jetzt können wir das doch mal ausprobieren also wir brauchen eine neue vm
Leute
Soll ich mal die cute vm starten die habe ich einfach nur da um sie starten zu können um euch kurz zu erfreuen
Und dann mache ich sie wieder aus
Achtung cute vm startet nur für euch
So alles klar leute ich hoffe ihr seid jetzt nicht geblendet
Weird champ
Gut entweder das wir heute auch erledigt können wir wieder ausmachen
Das ist übrigens wer sich fragt was das ist
Das ist mau bunthu eine äußerst äußerst vertrauenswürdige seite wenn man drauf geht passt mal auf ich gehe mal kurz auf mau bunthu die seite sieht aus wie der letzte china chinesen scam
Die frage ist warum das nicht dein main os ist ja kann man sich wirklich fragen
Mau bunthu
Ich habe immer angst auf diese seite drauf zu gehen weil ich denke ich lande auf irgendeiner scam china china waritz malware download seite
Wer schon immer mal sein ubuntu vibifizieren wollte der liegt hier genau richtig gut haben wir das geklärt mal ausmachen die vm für endeavor os an
Ich habe immer noch so eine uralte version drauf
Das haben wir glaube ich schon ein paar mal festgestellt
Ich bewege die maus nicht mehr guck mal ich bewege die maus nicht mehr und es kommt nicht hinterher
Die zeichen des fenster aus irgendwelchen gründen selbst und es backt rum wie sau
Obunthu 64 bit
Das andere ja löschen wenn wir es mal nach stream an dem moment nicht z doppelpunkt users wir wollen nicht dahin wir wollen e doppelpunkt
Vms
Bester vm name
3 cpus oder 3 cores 8 g ram
Nattes okay wenn ihr nicht von außen drauf zugreifen jawoll jawoll new disc ja new disc 40 g
Yep customize hardware wir schmeißen den drucker raus
So dann schauen wir uns das ganze doch mal an wieviel ram bräuchte man damit das in einer vm nicht so lag bei mir das kommt drauf an das liegt wahrscheinlich gar nicht am ram bei dir was benutzt du denn
Grafische also desktop oberflächen die irgendwelche grafischen extrawürste machen wollen die funktionieren nicht richtig in der vm also nicht das heißt nicht richtig die funktionieren schon okay in der vm aber nicht wirklich so richtig snappy richtig gut
Am besten ist sowas simples wie 3 zu haben weil das eben keine keine großartigen effekte hat du kannst also was du machen kannst ist du kannst accelerate 3d craft das mache ich jetzt an der stelle aber du kannst accelerate 3d graphics machen
Dann kann die vm open gl und sowas machen aber ganz ehrlich das funktioniert schon aber am besten ist es wenn du in der vm irgendwas benutzt was easy auf grafikseite ist
Ich meine ich benutze i3 bei i3 gibt es eigentlich nichts an irgendwie sperenzien oder so also i3 ist halt einfach nur desktop noch ein desktop und noch ein desktop und noch ein desktop ohne irgendwelche geschichten dabei
So machen wir das mal use image download moment wo ist es denn hier da zack kurz noch mal chat gucken ach moin jvpeak huge auch wieder am start poggers
Was mich bis heute nervt dass die vms auf sich wusste ich gar nicht dass sie das sind gibt es gibt es eigentlich schon einen speedrun blue screen any percent oder sowas
Kennst du das hier anime girls holding programming box moment was ach ja das kenne ich das kenne ich das kenne ich das ist aber richtig richtig harter weep content
Richtig harter weep content hier
Wollen wir mal C++ gucken
Game programming in C++
I3 braucht 32 MB RAM habe ich noch nie nachgeguckt aber hättest du mich gefragt schätz mal wie viel i3 braucht standardmäßig hätte ich sagen unter 100 MB
Ja alte Apple Hardware verkauft sich tatsächlich relativ gut
Echt so also machen wir mal an
Ja ja ich habe finished geinstalt so also wo kann man jetzt auswählen was für ein Flavor man haben will vielleicht vielleicht wisst ihr was wir machen jetzt mal was was wir nie was wir wirklich nie machen
Und zwar wir gucken mal in die ins in das Installationsdokument von denen was sie da sagen
Ok da gibt es nicht so viel zu gucken also booten wir mal machen wir das hier mal kurz stretch
So auf gehts default Nvidia
Und an der Stelle einmal kurz Exclusive Mode spätestens jetzt würden die Noobs schon nervös vom Rechner sitzen was ist das Text
Kein GUI ich fläbe aus das ist doch nur was für echte Hackermans hier
Das sind wir in einer riesig krassen Auflösung von 640 mal 480 oder 800 mal 600 oder sonst was
Ok install start ich kann nicht sprechen Leute Summa Summa Hirn Start Installer ist das Windows 12
Ja ja genau jetzt ist es ist das Jahr des Linux Desktops Leute aber gucken was wir für Auflösung kriegen
Aber vielleicht bis sie bis sie was nicht ganz so eklig das Wahnsinn ich meine ich installiere später e-vmw tools
Installation Tipps
Das haben wir doch gerade ist ja gut virtual box ja ne das haben wir eigentlich mehr oder weniger das haben wir auch gemacht
Ok müssen wir nichts machen also auf gehts Start Installer
Moment install Community Editions
Ok online online
Wie erstmal im Hintergrund irgendwelche Python Exceptions abgehen Ach das ist Calamares oder was den hier Installer
Verstehe
Wobei Calamares muss man cooler aussprechen Calamares oder Calamares wie sprechen wie sprechen die Amis den Calamares aus
Calamares pronunciation Calamares Nein das ist auf Deutsch Englisch
Calamari Nein Calamares zuviel Kokona Time schon wieder hier so auf Deutsch Nee
Auf Kokona Style American Englisch aber bitte schon mit deutschem Tastatur layout ich hoffe können wir gleich mal testen ob das ordentlich funktioniert
Das ist meine bevorzugte Variante Kokona Sprache und deutsches Tastatur layout Was sind das da oder
Take a screenshot
So Next Europe Berlin Next Keyboard Nein Keyboard ist German No Dead Keys
No Dead Keys ist dass man Zirkum Flex und und wie heißt wie heißt dieser Kram und Backticks und so dass man die machen kann ohne doppelt zu tippen
Ich weiß gar nicht wie die ganzen Dinger heißen hier die Zeichen aber ich finde es doof doppelt tippen zu müssen
Sekunde Chat Leute ich muss eins sagen zwei Sachen die richtig nice sind also eine Sache die nicht so gut ist ich bin müde wie Sau
Auch weil ich draußen geschafft habe aber bisschen was richtig nice ist mein Hals tut mir heute nicht weh
Vielleicht ist ja wirklich die Sache ich war übrigens beim Arzt gestern ich muss euch was erzählen noch bevor wir weitermachen
Ich hab wieder die pure zwei Klassen Medizin erlebt am Freitag
Ich hab mir einen HNO Arzt rausgesucht Frankfurt und hab da angerufen und der hat zwei Standorte
Der hat einen Standort wo er unter der Woche in einer Gemeinschaftspraxis ist und der hat einen Standort
noch mal eine andere Praxis wo er abends ist oder nachmittags ist und nur private Patienten macht
So ich hab mir den rausgesucht hab angerufen hab gesagt ja also Hals weh Husten Reuspern sonstwiegen
Das hab ich schon jetzt über vier Wochen dann muss ich mal jemand angucken und dann meinten die so ja also
Wenn sie hier zu unserer normalen Praxis kommen wollen dann ist es mindestens drei Wochen Wartezeit kostet aber nichts
Oder aber sie können heute Mittag 16.15 Uhr kommen und da müssen sie dann halt selbst bezahlen
Ich hab da ja eh schon angerufen weil ich gesagt hab ich bezahle selbst ja aber es ist einfach mittlerweile so offensichtlich
Dass es eine zwei Klassen Medizin gibt und wenn die schon die gleiche Sprechstundenhilfe dir das eins zu eins so sagt am Telefon
Da weißt du schon Bescheid aber ey okay ich mein mir solls Recht sein ich nehm lieber den Termin um 16.15 Uhr als dass ich drei Wochen warte
Und ich muss sagen hat sich gelohnt der war echt gut hingegangen das ist doch wisst ihr ich seh das bei meinem Hausarzt
Ja wenn du da mit versicherten Kerlchen hingehst denen wärs lieber du wirst gleich wieder heimgehen die wollen dich da eigentlich gar nicht
Und ich hatte bisher bis außer bei einem der hat mich gescampt äh was heißt gescampt der hat viel zu viel abgerechnet
Bisher zumindest dort wo ich selbst bezahlt hab bei den Ärzten immer ein gutes Gefühl dass man da gut aufgehoben ist
Die Leute am Empfang sind nett und man hat das Gefühl die sind quasi froh die freuen sich dir helfen zu können quasi
Und das ist der Unterschied ist wirklich riesengroß wie gesagt ich hab's wieder gemerkt
Ansonsten war der gut was ein bisschen was ein bisschen eklig ist kann ich euch sagen ich weiß nicht ob ihr schonmal eine Kehlkopf Spiegelung bekommen habt
Wobei so eklig war das nicht aber es ist vielleicht im ersten Moment ein bisschen eklig
Da kriegt ihr so ein Spiegelding in den Hals geschoben das ist so ein langer Stab mit Kamera Licht und Spiegel dran
Wo der Typ dann quasi dir in den Hals hinten ganz weit reingucken kann
Und das ist im ersten Moment denkst du erstmal so so aber dann gehts eigentlich ist es überhaupt nicht schlimm
So ok äh hell yeah freedom OS Pog ist es sinnvoll ich beantworte gleich was es gekostet hat Chat
Ich muss aber kurz den Chat hier der rein nach durchgehen sonst vergess ich die Hälfte wieder
Ist es sinnvoll ein Frontend Framework wie zum Beispiel Svelte zu verwenden oder ist es mehr aufwärts als nutzbringend
Das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab wie komplex und was du für eine Anwendung machen willst
Für super simple Sachen keine Ahnung Webseite mit dem Button drauf kannst du das alles mit Vanilla JavaScript machen ohne irgendwelche Zusatz Sachen
Aber ich persönlich finde dass ich auch schon bei wenig komplexen Seiten lohnt sowas wie Svelte oder auch Vue zu verwenden
Einfach weil es schneller und angenehmer von statten geht
Und gerade bei Svelte hast du den Vorteil das kompiliert sich ja sogar weg
Da ist ja dann gar nicht mehr so viel übrig
Ja so sieht es im Prinzip aus ja
Sowas selbst zu zahlen ist teuer
Nee erstaunlicherweise ist es als Selbstzahler beim Arzt gar nicht mal so teuer
Ich mein wenn ihr da jetzt hingeht und sagt ihr wollt eine Darmspiegelung machen und anschließend noch eine Schönheits-OP durchgeführt haben
Dann ist das natürlich teuer
Nee aber realistisch betrachtet so teuer ist das gar nicht
Weil private Ärzte können ja eh nicht abbrechen was sie wollen
Es gibt die Gebührenordnung für Ärzte
Und da steht drin was die Sachen kosten
Und da steht ein Satz dahinter
Also nehmen wir jetzt irgendwie was weiß ich nehmen wir mal irgendwas
Keine Ahnung Chirurgie ist halt teuer
Keine Ahnung Basisleistung hier Grundleistung hier was weiß ich
Oder was weiß ich Sonderleistung keine Ahnung Augenheilkunde
Steht dann steht dann sowas drin wie Erstanpassung, Auswahl, Kontaktlinsen irgendwie 13,29
Die Seite ist ziemlich beschissen gemacht weil normalerweise brauchst du noch den Satz den maximal zusätzlichen Satz nebenbei
Zumindest die Grundpreise stehen da drin
Und dann ist wichtig mit welchem Satz der Arzt abrechnet
Und der normale Satz den die abrechnen ist meistens mal 2 also das was hier drin steht mal 2,3 warum mal 2,3
Weil 2,3 der höchste Satz ist den man bei den meisten
Punkten in dieser Gebührenordnung abrechnen kann ohne dass du explizit quasi darauf hinweisen musst oder erklären musst warum du höhere Sätze abrechnen
Deswegen rechnen die meisten mal 2,3 ab aber was ich persönlich jetzt schon gemerkt habe ist ich war ja schon bei ein paar mittlerweile
Ich war glaube ich insgesamt bei 5 Ärzten bisher die ich privat also die ich selbst bezahlt habe
Wenn du die fragst so nach dem Motto was denn so der normale Satz ist wie die abrechnen
Oftmals sind die sogar günstiger als mal 2,3 also ich war mal für meine Mutter bei einem was war das
Orthopäde ne sowas was der sich um Hüftsachen kümmert in Frankfurt
Und der hat explizit gesagt nein bei selbst bei selbst zahlen wir rechnen nur einfachen Satz ab
Das heißt am Ende sind wir dann damit 105 Euro oder so rausgegangen und insgesamt wurden wir und jetzt haltet euch mal fest
Insgesamt wurde sie nicht wir sie wurde insgesamt zweimal behandelt und insgesamt 45 Minuten
Also das beim ersten Mal mit 30 Minuten drin beim zweiten 15 Minuten
Ich bin mit weil ich ja wissen wollte für was ich da Geld bezahle am Ende haben wir 105 Euro bezahlt
Wo werdet ihr bei welchem normalen Arzt behandelt euch 45 Minuten
Da müsst ihr nach fünf Minuten wieder raus sein weil die kein Bock mehr auf euch haben
Wenn ich überlege zwischen ASP.NET Core Server-Site Rendering und.NET Core API mit 12.100 da erscheint mir erst das einfache oder
Ja für sag mal besonders datengetriebene Webseiten ist das so
Aber sobald es dynamischer wird ist JavaScript Frontend in der Regel das Mittel der Wahl
Der neueste Trend ist aber das zu kombinieren
Der neueste Trend ist sowas wie SvelteKit zum Beispiel oder wie heißt das bei React Nuxt oder so
Next Nuxt ist Vue.js glaube ich zu verwenden
Und da kannst du dann solche Sachen machen wie dass du die Seiten schon vorrenderst auf dem Server
Und dann hydratest so nennt sich das quasi den ganzen State einfrierst und mit an den Client schickst
Das heißt die Seite ist schon mal ready to go läuft dann aber wird an den Client geschickt
Wird aber zum Beispiel sowas wie SvelteKit kannst du das machen
Die Seite wird quasi beim ersten Mal abrufen vorgerendert auf dem Server so komplett fertig
Dann wird es an den Client geschickt der Client dehydratet das zurück in eine reine Single Page Application
Und lässt sie dann weiter bei sich im Browser laufen
Das ist halt das Coole du hast steht ja auch hier du hast was was Suchmaschinen crawlen können
Was wichtig ist was normale Single Page Applications nicht haben
Und du hast den Vorteil von Frontend Sachen dass du eben dynamisch schön auf Änderungen reagieren kannst
Animationen machen und live updaten und sowas wofür Frontend Single Page Applications gut sind
Das ist so der neueste Trend und die eigentlichen Web Frameworks die werden heute zum größten Teil
Das behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal ich hab da keine Statistik oder so
Werden zum größten Teil eigentlich rein als AP Endpoints noch verwendet
Also im Prinzip ist das was du mit ASP.NET Core machst die Datenbank im Hintergrund mit Entity Framework plus
Irgendeine REST API oder CraftQL davor als Endpunkte HTML Rendern ist tatsächlich meines Erachtens mittlerweile relativ selten da drin
Und das machst du eher in Kombination mit irgendeinem Toolkit für dein jeweiliges Frontend Framework
Ja so
Ringverdiener dürfen sich hier anstellen wie gesagt selbst bezahlen beim Arzt es ist günstiger als man denkt
Also wenn du da einfach nur hingehst und sagst hier was weiß ich stellt euch stellt euch mal vor ihr habt irgendwie
Ihr habt längere Zeit Halsweh oder ihr habt irgendwie Verdauungsprobleme irgendwie so die 0815 Geschichten
Übrigens auch private Ärzte dürfen euch krank schreiben also es ist nicht so dass ihr da hingeht
Und der euch keine Krankmeldung geben kann für den Arbeitgeber das geht auch
Also du kannst dich auch krank schreiben lassen von einem privaten Arzt das ist gar kein Problem
Und wenn ihr einfach mal sagt ich schleppe jetzt schon was wirklich hier 3-4 Wochen mit mir rum
Ich würde gerne mal zu einem Arzt der sich auch für interessiert und der mir auch zuhört
Und der auch ein bisschen Zeit da rein steckt da müsst ihr nicht irgendwie damit riesen riesen Kosten rechnen
Also dann sucht ihr euch irgendeinen raus sagt ihr bezahlt selbst
Und ihr fragt ihr am besten gleich noch dabei mit welchem Besatz sie standardmäßig so abrechnen
Und wenn der bei euch nichts großes macht dann kann der jetzt ja auch nicht Gott und die Welt abrechnen
Also ich sag mal in der Regel liegt man so zwischen 50 und 150 Euro
Ihr habt aber den Vorteil es geht meistens wahnsinnig schnell
Ihr ruft da an und der sagt ja komm kommen sie vorbei sobald es passt
Und ihr werdet besser behandelt und ganz ehrlich die meisten Leute geben ihr Geld doch eh entweder entweder für unsinnigen Stuss aus
Oder machen sie weg geben ihr Geld gar nicht aus
Das beste was ihr machen könnt ist aber ganz ehrlich
Bevor man sich jetzt einen neuen Fernseher kauft für 7000 Euro
Da kann man auch mal für 150 Euro zum Arzt gehen wenn man schon 3-4 Wochen oder ein paar Monate Probleme hat
Deswegen mache ich das auch ab und zu und wie gesagt ich habe es letzten Freitag wieder gesehen
Komplett zwei Klassenmedizin ich hätte mindestens 3 Wochen warten müssen auf den Termin
Und dadurch dass ich selbst bezahlt habe ich sofort bekommen habe ich natürlich auch gemacht weil ich wollte ja schnell dran
Also ich persönlich finde es ok ich finde es rein für mich gesehen finde ich es gut dass es die Möglichkeit gibt
Auf der anderen Seite kann man sich natürlich schon fragen ob es nicht ein bisschen unfair ist für Leute die sich das nicht leisten können
So hatte mal angerufen was hatte mal wo angerufen ja wir schließen jetzt ja ok ist ein Arbeitsunfall
Ja ok Arbeitsunfall ist ja wieder was anderes Arbeitsunfall musst du ja sogar zum wie nennt sich das Betriebsnähe
Zu irgendeinem Arzt der von der von der Berufsgenossenschaft ist oder so musst du hin
Und Unfall durchgehend irgendwas genau du musst zu irgendeinem Arzt dass du das dann auch meldest
Also wenn du einen Arbeitsunfall hast musst du das melden
Ein Kollege von mir beispielsweise ist mal auf dem Heimweg zum Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
Banken Frankfurt ist ja alles entweilt vom Hauptbahnhof weg gelaufen und da war eine Platte im Bürgersteig nicht fest
Und der ist auf diese Platte draufgetreten und ist quasi ein Meter mit dem ein Meter mit dem Bein im Boden reingefahren instant
Weil die Platte nicht fest war und hat sich das hat sich das Knie mega aufgeschlagen dabei
Er hat übelst weh getan und der ist dann heim und ist nicht zum Durchgangsarzt und nicht zum Arzt gegangen wegen Betriebsunfall
Tag danach war sein Knie doppelt so doppelt und dreifach so dick aber der Kerl ist mega hart im Leben
Der war trotzdem arbeiten, der hat irgendwie so ein riesen dickes Knie gehabt und meinte noch hier Betriebsarbeitsunfall
Hat das hat das quasi sogar glaube ich seinem Chef gesagt war aber nie bei diesem Arzt um das feststellen zu lassen
Und im Prinzip jetzt ist zu spät
Jetzt ist jetzt ist jetzt ist zu spät weil jetzt hat er wieder Probleme mit seinem Knie
Okay ich habe keine Ahnung was da im Chat gerade abgeht aber ich glaube ich muss mal ein paar Timeouts raushauen
So wie gesagt was ich gezahlt habe weiß ich noch nicht die Rechnung kriege ich noch aber wie gesagt das wird sich im Rahmen von 50 bis 150 Euro bewegen
Macht das leider auch auf zu aber ist eigentlich schon ja ist es irgendwo schon ich wie gesagt ich kann mich da nicht beschweren
Ich habe ich habe ja die Möglichkeit aber insgesamt ist schon ein bisschen fragwürdig
Kriegen die eigentlich weniger Geld bei den Versicherten? Ja gut das kommt drauf an das muss man das muss man aufteilen
Wenn du zu einem Arzt gehst der nur Privatversicherte nimmt dann kann der dann darf der gar keine Kassenversicherten behandeln
Der hat keine Zulassung von der von der Krankenkasse das darf der gar nicht
Und ansonsten wenn es ein Arzt ist der beides nimmt was ja die Regel ist also du kannst ja bei sagen bei bei allen Ärzten die Kassen nehmen
Eigentlich davon ausgehen denn selbstverständlich nimmt er auch private und Selbstzahler weil es mehr Geld bringt
Ja das ist tatsächlich so das was du mit dieser Gebührenordnung abrechnen kannst ist um einiges ich bin natürlich da kein Experte
Aber ist um einiges höher als was du von der Krankenkasse bekommst
Zumal du ja im zweifelsfall das mal 2,3 mit einem höheren Satz sogar abrechnen kannst noch also kriegst eh schon mehr und dann kannst du es auch nochmal verdoppeln
Also ja du kriegst du kriegst von einem Selbstzahler beziehungsweise generell von einem Privatversicherten kriegst du viel mehr raus als Arzt als von einem gesetzlich Versicherten
Deswegen sind die natürlich auch happy wenn Leute zu ihnen kommen und Privatversichert sind und oder eben nicht Privatversichert sind oder halt auch Selbstbezahlen
Und deswegen gibt es da auch so einen gewissen Wettbewerb weil es ist einfach so das muss man sich ja auch mal vergegenwertigen im Kopf
Die Leute die selbst bezahlen oder Privatversichert sind die haben sie schon so einen gewissen Anspruch
Wenn da einer anruft und sagt ja ich bezahle selbst ich bräuchte einen Termin und die sagen ihm kommen sie in vier Monaten wieder
Und dann haben sie noch eine Wartezeit von zwei Stunden dann sagt er nö da suche ich mir was anderes
Also die haben und bei gesetzlich Versicherten ist das nicht so das kann der letzte das kann der letzte Abwachs sein
Arzt unfähig Arzt unfreundlich Sprechen Sprechen und Hilfe unfreundlich die Leute müssen da trotzdem hin
Also was sie müssen sie müssen nicht aber die Ärzte sind trotzdem überlaufen für gesetzlich Versicherte
Die haben da gar keinen wirklichen Konkurrenzdruck das ist im privaten Bereich nicht so
Weil wenn ich da einmal hingehe und da scan mich wie beispielsweise der HNO Arzt in Frankfurt
Wo ich mal hingegangen bin weil mein Ohr morgens auf einmal verstopft war
Der mir da irgendwie 70 Euro oder sowas abgerechnet hat für zwei Minuten mal ins Ohr gucken und sauber machen
Da gehe ich nie wieder hin Pech gehabt einmal gescannt nie wieder
Toxy Dankeschön 25.000 Subscriptions und das ist halt so ich muss da nicht hin
Ich sage einfach nö vergiss es gehe ich nie wieder hin suche mir das andere gibt es ja noch gibt es ja genug
Ja das kommt auch noch dabei ein Hausarzt kann so die Basic ich glaube es geht nur die Basic Sachen
So die Basic Leistung nur einmal im Quartal abbrechen also umso öfter du zu deinem Hausarzt gehts im Quartal umso weniger verdient er an dir
Also ja du bekommst deutlich deutlich mehr bei einem Selbstzahler oder Privatversicherten als gesetzlich Versicherten
Kann man nein nein nein nein das geht nicht
Das geht es gibt einen Fall der mir bekannt ist wo das geht und das sind Psychologen
Weil Psychologen und Therapeuten in der Regel sagen sie machen das gar nicht mehr für den Kassensatz
Und die Kasse ist ja sie sind ja verpflichtet quasi die im Zweifelsfall einen zu nennen der dich behandeln kann
Wenn das war wenn das keiner machen will und die finden da keine mehr
Also zu Therapeuten und Psychologen ist das einzige wo ich schon mal gehört habe dass das möglich ist aber auch nur im im Vorfeld
Wenn man das geklärt hat in der Regel nein also du kannst nicht auf eigene Faust zum privaten Arzt gehen
Und dann sagen Krankenversicherung bezahlt mir mal wenigstens euren Anteil was ich persönlich richtig dumm finde
Ehrlich gesagt weil ich bezahle doch schon meine Krankenkassenbeiträge warum soll ich nicht zu einem privaten gehen dürfen
Den Aufpreis bezahlen und den Rest bezahlt die Krankenkasse das ist was was ich nicht verstehe
Das würde ich sehr begrüßen wenn man da irgendwas ändern würde
Wir haben immer noch nicht angefangen aber gut ich komme gar nicht hinterher
Aber wofür zahle ich dann 500 ja das fragt man sich na na gut Krankenkasse bezahlt
Wenn du 500 Euro bezahlt dann bist du wahrscheinlich privat versichert weil 500 Euro oder du verdienst super krass viel oder keine Ahnung
Wobei ehrlich gesagt ich weiß gar nicht wie viel ich bezahle im Monat
Aber wahrscheinlich ich glaube so viel ist es nicht
Und ansonsten ist halt die Sache die Krankenkasse bezahlen ist halt so eine Wette wie bei Versicherungen so üblich
Du bezahlst weil du es vielleicht irgendwann mal brauchst
Und es dann so teuer wird dass du dir das nie leisten könntest
Das ist ja die Sache auch mit Krankenversicherung oder auch gerade privaten Krankenversicherung
Du lässt dich Krankenversichern weil du quasi abgesichert sein möchtest dass wenn du mal wirklich krank wirst und es so teuer wird
Dass du es nicht einfach bezahlen könnt nicht mehr bezahlen könntest
Und dich nicht mehr behandeln lassen könntest deswegen bist du Krankenversichert
Du könntest ja auch sagen ey ich leg ein bisschen Geld zur Seite die 100 150 Euro wenn die ich mal zwischendurch brauche habe ich und ich spare Geld
Das machen die Amis ja ist ja mein Amis sehr beliebt Geld nicht in die Krankenversicherung zu stecken
Es gibt keine Befehle ich kann auf meinem Monitor hier draufklicken du kannst da nichts machen
Ja das ist richtig aber eine privaten Krankenversicherung ist halt noch teurer
Ich muss sagen ich fahre damit eigentlich ganz gut ich bin gesetzlich versichert
Und wenn ich mal Sonderwurst brauche Sonderbehandlung brauche
Schnell Termin brauche oder mich ordentlich mal behandeln lassen will dann bezahle ich selbst
Sobald es natürlich dann in die tausende gehen würde dann würde ich irgendwie schauen dass ich das anderweitig mache
Ansonsten ist privaten Krankenversicherung heute auch eine Wette drauf ob du es brauchst also dass du abgesichert bist wenn du es brauchst
Wenn du es sollst nicht mehr bezahlen kannst ansonsten fährst du natürlich so wie ich es mache günstiger
Weil ich eben die was weiß ich 250 Euro noch mal obendrauf im Monat mir spare
Und ich gehe keine Ahnung ich gehe zwei drei mal im Jahr vielleicht zu einem Arzt weil weil ich irgendwie was gucken lassen will
Und wenn wenn ich den selbst wenn ich die alle selbst bezahlen würde wäre ich immer noch deutlich günstiger
Zumindest mit meinem aktuellen Gesundheitszustand der ganz okay ist als wenn ich privat versichert wäre
Oder kann man sich drüber streiten ja habe ich gemacht bin aber nicht ganz fertig
Wie gesagt das musst du wissen kann ich dir so pauschal nicht sagen
Toxy danke für den Sub 25 Monate real razor schief danke für den Sub
Tja ich habe mich mal Scam lassen für 70 Euro
Ja gut das ist halt die Ami Taktik aber ich habe das Gefühl bei den Amis sind die Arztpreis auch richtig krass teuer wie weit bei Linux
Passt mal auf nach einer Stunde
TS Fox danke für den Sub
Es gibt keine E-Mode Commands
Ich drück oder meinst du das Prefix für meine E-Modes im Chat zum Beispiel sowas hier
Das ist Wupp als Prefix Wupp Wupp Ach der zeigt gar nicht die normalen E-Modes an warum das denn nicht
Das sind nur die Better Twitch TV E-Modes die der anzeigt meine normalen E-Modes zeigt da gar nicht an
Ok Leute auf gehts
Oh das ist irgendwie Sehenscheinentzündung oder sowas
Ok weiter jetzt jetzt gucken wir uns aber die Linux Geschichten an also wir sind German Keyboard Next Erase Disk natürlich alles weg
Bam Chat übrigens wenn ihr nur Fragen habt wegen Privatbezahlen Ärzte so haut raus ja ich habe den Kram jetzt ein paar mal gemacht
Wenn ihr da irgendwie unsicher seid ich sage nicht dass ich alles weiß oder irgendwas wissen wollt
Fragt mich im Chat ich sage es euch glaube das ist für alle auch ganz interessant
Nö brauchen wir nicht Erase Disk gib ihm was macht er denn eigentlich dann
Ok 40G direkt Aha hier kann man jetzt auswählen was man haben will Base und Firefox Language Packages
Ok Base also ich kriege ein X ich kriege ein Netzwerk ich kriege Fonts ich kriege Audio
Ok und hier kann ich die Desktops aufheben Chat was für einen Desktop wollen wir als erstes uns mal anschauen
Ich werde an der Stelle mal kurz ein Snapshot machen
Also ich immer wieder hier drin zurückspringen kann KDE ihr wisst ich kenne mich mit KDE 0 aus ich habe gar keinen Plan von KDE
Der Knob der Scheiß Knob KDE wir machen mal Plasma Plasma wo ist das denn wo ist das denn
Ach hier heißt es KDE ich meine wisst ihr was warum installieren wir nicht einfach alles
Wir installieren einfach alles und wählen es dann aus fertig easy
Firefox warum soll man warum soll man mehrfach installieren
Dann mache ich jetzt einfach den Snapshot weg
Dann mache ich den Snapshot weg weil Snapshots werden bei sowas immer relativ schnell relativ pepo pepo fett
LXDE braucht keiner ist LXDE nicht die alte Version von LXQT
Oder wird es noch weiterentwickelt
Ich mach das jetzt alles Printing Support KekWaite KekWaite KekWaite
So Next habe ich was oben vergessen LTS Kernel Editions
Quatsch LTS Kernel so alter Shit wir wollen Pleading Edge
Your Name Qt Qt Chat Qt Chat Forever Virtual Platform
Ja bester bester Computer Name über wobei das ist dann auf dem Terminal so lang
Qt Chat Abkürzung CC Passwort
1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
Huge Passwort nein jawoll
Next Summary alles klar install gib ihm
Install hast du schon mal den Zen Kernel getestet
Nein den haben schon ich getestet was ist das
Aber keine Ahnung was ist das Zen Kernel
Ich habe nur eine GitHub Repo gerade gefunden
Du weißt mein Passwort und meine IP Fuck
Jetzt ist vorbei
Schon eingehackt
Linux Kernel was optimiert für Performance und speziell für Gaming
Warum nicht ja soll jeder machen was er will
Cheesy Pro 36 Version 2 10 Monate Dankeschön für den Sub
Massive Subscription um nicht zu sagen
Was Meinung zu Sushirin David ich weiß nicht mal wer das ist
Das ist irgendeine Beauty Youtuberin oder
Keine Ahnung ich habe noch nicht ein Video von der gesehen
Was ich installiere Endeavor OS das ist mehr Arch Linux als Manjaro
Also Arch by the way so richtig echtes Arch by the way
Manjaro ist ja kein Arch by the way
Warum nicht
Yes
Ist die Festplatte voll
Okay nice was war jetzt das Problem
Was ist jetzt das
Installer wo ist denn das Installer hier in Hut oder
Wo liegt denn das Installer
Nicht change lock
Ah ja okay
Wartet mal vorher wir machen mal kurz noch die
Die Screen die Screen resolution besser
Okay zeig her was hatte für Schmerze
Was hatte für Schmerze zeige ich her
View Manager install Package Manager
Package Manager could not make changes to the install system
Command pacman return error code 2
Skipping dependencies
Was ist daran so geil es ist ein Arch Linux mit Arch Package mit Arch
Repos und nicht wie Manjaro mit so einem 2 Wochen
Verzögerten zumindest ist es das was viele als Vorteile sehen
Ich habe keine Ahnung wo das Problem hier dran ist
Ich habe zu viel auf einmal installiert
The command pacman create probiere mal weniger ja mache ich jetzt auch
Start Installer online
Ich weiß was wir noch mal machen können ist
BLK ID wir gehen auch mal auf SCA
Haben wir das überhaupt hier
STA1 Nö also am Festplattenplatz kannst du wirklich nicht liegen
Okay also welcome
Start Installer
Nein ich will es nicht auf Deutsch ich will es auf vielleicht war Kocona das Problem
Vielleicht machen wir britisch Englisch
Europe
Ja man
No dead key
Hoi
Was passiert wenn ich jetzt einfach auf weiter klick
Ich kann nicht weiter klingen
Ich muss jetzt manuell partitionieren
Na gut das ist ja relativ easy
Kann ich einfach sagen benutze das
Ne Delete
Geht das so jetzt ich hoffe ich mache das richtig
Ich hoffe jetzt einfach mal das ist richtig was ich hier gemacht habe
Gpt partition ist best
Go back and set partition seriously leute
Kann ich einfach sagen mach alles und gut ist
Okay also muss ich jetzt wirklich sagen
Delete warum gibt es das ist schon wieder blöd gemacht warum gibt es jetzt kein mach
Einfach drüber und scheiß drauf
Create
Keine Ahnung
Kann man nicht ein bisschen weniger machen
Irgendwie so
Mountpoint slash
Und was soll ich jetzt machen noch irgendeine Gpt oder sowas was hat er mir erzählt
Create geht nicht mehr
Nochmal create geht nicht
Anni hier create
Und jetzt was
Gut
Nee
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Wow
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht
Delete
To configure Gpt partition table und Bios
Go back and set a partition table
To Gpt next grader 8mb unformatted
Bios scrub flag enabled
Okay unformatted free space
Anni unformatted soll ich machen create
Unformatted
Mit bios bios scrub
Alles klar
Ob das jetzt mal funktioniert
Hab ich doch
Oder muss es exakt 8mb groß sein
Okay create
Acht das ist falsche
Oh nee jetzt habe ich
Create
Mountpoint
Slash okay wunderbar
New partition ist die hier
Edit genau 8 8 8
Okay okay so
Alles klar
Next
Okay ich habe keine Ahnung was der was der für Schmerzen hat von mir
Ich lasse ihn jetzt einfach mal installieren
So xfc kde gnome i3 made cinnamon
Okay wisst ihr was ich mache jetzt
Ich mache jetzt mal nur die da und mache jetzt hier einen snapshot
Ach scheiß drauf ich brute das Ding einfach neu
Next
Cute chat
1 2 3 4 5 6
Jawoll next
Ja perfekt genauso muss das sein
Install
Was
Warum
Okay gepartet
Ist das drauf
Flush jetzt einfach alles auf meiner Festplatte
Hallo
Wo ist der Apply Knopf das da
Jaja ignore scheiß drauf Klaus
Vielleicht muss ich nochmal an mounten
Muss ich das nochmal an mounten vielleicht
Nee ist alles an mounten okay püren wir den Installer nochmal aus
Okay das ist schon eine kompliziertere Geschichte stelle ich gerade fest
Nuke die vor allem und fang von vorn an ja
Kann es ja nicht sein so location Berlin
German
No dead keys
Hier Erase this BAM Gibi
Next
Okay wir machen jetzt nur
KDE Gnome Desktop oder
Mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
Cute chat
1 2 3 4 5 6
Und jetzt next install
BAM und jetzt gibi
Okay ich starte die vm nochmal neu
Wie gut
Geht ja gut los
Funktioniert ja optimal alles hier
Also ich glaube an der Installation gescheitert sind wir bisher noch bei keinem
Linux
Wo ist das Problem das startet gar nicht mehr jetzt guck mal das ist komplett broken
Das boot noch nicht mal mehr
Alles boot das versucht gerade von der Festplatte zu booten kann das sein
CD Rom
Ja
Aber ich habe die Festplatte doch gelöscht
Ich sehe schon komm ich muss die Platte nochmal abhängen und nochmal neu dranhängen
Weil weil broken
Versuch normales Arch mit nein
Ich will ja explizit das da ausprobieren jetzt
Gerade der Witz muss ja funktionieren kann nicht sein dass es schon an der Installation
Scheitert
Du spams den Endeavor Eier sie
Nee lass die mal in Ruhe
Das müssen wir auch so hinkriegen
Kann ja nicht sein
So also dann starten wir das ganze nochmal neu
Erst mal die Display Resolution wieder auf was und daran wird es jetzt an ihr liegen
So
Start Installer online
Willst du was trinken? Hydrated Stain?
Britisch Englisch
Oi
Next
Nochmal das gleiche
No Deadkeys
Erase
Oh nee jetzt gehts wieder kaputt
Ich sag euch es geht aus irgendwelchen Kunden wahrscheinlich wieder kaputt
KDE Gnome XFCE
Lull
Hast du überhaupt eine Netzwerkverbindung?
Also
Ich sollte eigentlich eine Netzwerkverbindung haben also sagen wir mal andersrum
Mich würde äußerst wundern
Wenn ich keine Netzwerkverbindung hätte
Ich hab ne Netzwerkverbindung
Halt guck hier
Terminal
King google.de
Bäm Kunst
Und wo auch immer da die Antwort kommt
Von irgendeinem Router würde ich sagen
Next install
Install now
Aha
Jetzt tut sich schon was
Jetzt tut sich schon was ok
Was was ist denn
Das Bildschirm mit dem X
Das ist ein Screenshot Tool
Und das soll eine Schere sein und kein X
Das ist das ganz normale XFCE Screenshot
Ausruhzeichen
Aha
So hoffen wir mal dass der Krempel jetzt funzt
Neues Betriebssystem
Ich weiß gar nicht wie neu das ist
Ich hab das heute auf Reddit gesehen
Irgendjemand hat gesagt
In einem Reddit Post wo es darum ging
Irgendwie 21 Gründe warum einer nicht mehr Manjaro verwenden will
Meinte er ich habe jetzt Endeavor OS und viel geiler und so
Da hab ich mir gedacht wir probieren das jetzt mal aus
Ein Vorteil gegenüber Arch muss ja zumindest gegenüber Manjaro
Muss ja sein
Dass die keine Zwischen Repos haben
Sondern die offiziellen Arch Repos überall verwenden
Das ist auch das einzige was ich bisher so an richtig plus gesehen hab
Krelax Danke schön für den Sub
23 Monate
Falscher Knopf ich wollte eigentlich das hier drücken
Versammlung
Die Zeitzone ist falsch
Wir haben nicht 21 Uhr 14 wir haben 20 Uhr 14
Hast du Erfahrung mit Linux übers Netzwerk Booten
Ja
Alle ich hab mehr oder weniger ich sag nicht alles
Aber das meiste davon schon mal gemacht
Ich hab sogar mal den Raspberry Pi über NFS gebootet
PXE ist eigentlich ziemlich Standard net install
Reine Read Only Systeme mit mit Ram Disk
Ich hab eigentlich das meiste schon mal irgendwie gemacht
Ab 23 Monate gibt es eine AC 130
23 Kills 23er Streak genau
Kann ich mit Wistle Basic 6 Website programmieren
Bestimmt Irgendwie
Auch wenn das Obvious Debate ist aber
Irgendwie
Gibt es bestimmt einen Web Server für Wistle Basic 6
Jetzt hat es funktioniert
Restart
Geht es mit Kobold Ich weiß nicht ob es einen Web Server mit Kobold gibt
Leute Restart funktioniert nicht
Ach dann
Ich bin mal gespannt ob die Vmware Tools standardmäßig drauf haben
Was meint ihr haben die standardmäßig Vmware Tools drauf
123456 Mal gucken wo wir hier landen
Das ist
Das sieht aus wie ein Gnome oder
Der Scheiß Gnome ist das
Nur so erstmal kurz Vmware Tools installieren
130 Milliarden Terminals okay
Kein Dark Theme Leute
Aha
KDE hat kein Dark Theme, Xfc hat ein Dark Theme
Alles klar
Sudo minus I
Was haben wir hier J
Boah wie heißen denn diese Tools Open Vm Tools
Alles klar Open Vm Tools brauchen wir jetzt
Yes
Vmware
User
Nein
Vmware Tools funktionieren nicht
System
System CTL
Status V
Tools D Service
Active Running
Restart
Aha
Enable
Sehr schön okay
Also was haben wir denn hier am Start
Wir sind unterwegs in einem
Was ist das
Das ist ein Gnome 3 oder
Ja das sieht man hier schon an den Activities
Hat Gnome 3 keine Desktops mehr
Keine Desktop Icons mehr
Ich verwende Gnome 3 nicht
Ich hab
Wie starte ich denn Anwendungen so
Wer mit Gnome 3 nicht war und wie kriege ich das jetzt auf dem Desktop
Add to Favorites
Wie kriege ich das hier auf dem Desktop
Wie kriege ich denn was auf dem Desktop
Also ihr wisst ich benutze keine Desktops normalerweise
Also
Mein I3 hat auch keinen Desktop aber wenn man schon sowas hat
Es gibt keinen Desktop
Gnome hat per default keine Desktop Icons okay
Change Background
Okay das Dark Theme ist nicht wirklich dark
Das Dark Theme ist eigentlich Light Theme was aussieht wie ein Dark Theme
Was das ist natürlich auch schon komisch
Kann man in Gnome
Irgendwie
Dark Theme oder so einstellen wie nennt man
Wie gesagt ich verwende nie Gnome ich bin da ein kompletter Kacknoob drinne
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Gnome Thiems oder sowas einstellen
Man braucht immer noch Gnome Tweaks
Ich weiß schon warum ich Linux Desktop alles außer I3 nicht ab kann
I3 mag ich auch nur weil I3 eigentlich nichts macht
KDE ist mir brutalst überladen Gnome check ich nicht wie man das überhaupt verwenden kann
Na gut so
Wie log ich überhaupt aus
So okay Gnome ist schon mal raus
Was haben wir denn vorinstalliert
Hab ich noch nicht mal ein normales Menü wo ich jetzt was auswählen kann
Also mal angenommen ich wüsste nicht dass ich Firefox hab
Ich geb hier Chrome ein es gibt kommt kein Browser
Hab ich ein normales Menü
Wo ich irgendwie durchklicken könnte oder so
Ah okay okay
Da kann man sich jetzt aber Usability technisch echt irgendwie bisschen überstreiten oder
Es ist ja auch nicht kopiert nach irgendwas es ist einfach random alles drinne
Elisa ist am Start
Ah das ist ein Audio Player
Wenn ich wirklich
Boah da wär ich ja nie drauf gekommen
Der Dragon Player
Okay da sieht gar nichts also
Wisst ihr was das coolste an diesem Dragon Player
Ist eindeutig mal das Logo vom Icon
Der Rest sieht eher aus so wie 2002
Tweaks
Meine Güte
Gnome ist wirklich mega pains Champ
Kann man jetzt hier Dark Mode wenigstens machen
Hör mal auf Gnome
Gnome kann ich mir nicht geben da krieg ich Anfälle
Logout yes
So KDE Next
Wie switch ich überhaupt den Desktop
Hier ohne
Aha Plasma
Nice okay ihr findet das schon immer mal ganz gut dass am Anfang so ein Ding so ein Ding aufgeht
Was haben wir hier? Assistant, Update System, Update Mirrors, Pack-A-Diff, Meld
Browse our Packages
Ja super
Browse Arch Packages alles im Browser das krieg ich auch so hin
Add more apps, Kernel Manager
Proceed with Installation
Ach das installiert nur oder was
Ach ich kann Chrome noch zusätzlich installieren
Fireball GUI brauche ich nicht
LibreOffice
LibreOffice ii
Also nicht i weil LibreOffice ist sondern i weil ihr wisst ich bin generell kein Fan von Office Programmen
Ja Chrome schadet nicht
Chrome ist nie verkehrt so Tipps
Assistant, Update Mirrors, Update System
Nothing to update, ja nice
After Install, Update Mirrors, Package Cleanup, Config, Config
Default Wallpaper
Choose Wallpaper, da gibt es ja nicht so viele
Das ist aber auch ziemlich random oder
Ich mein warum ist denn bitteschön der File Browser hier links schwarz und da in hell das ist ja blö
Ich sag gleich dazu würde mich überhaupt nicht interessieren weil ich würde eh gleich i3 drauf schmeißen und hätte nichts von diesem Desktop Krempel
Dolphin File Manager, ah der sieht schon gleich besser aus
Jo
Das sieht eigentlich ganz gut, ich meine das ist halt so ein Standard File Manager Ding
Aber immer noch tausendmal besser zu gebrauchen als der Gnome Krempel
Was haben wir denn sonst am Start, System Settings
Ok KDE System Settings da werde ich jetzt nicht reingehen weil KDE System Settings dafür sorgt dass du durchdrehst
KDE ist das optionreichste Ding was es überhaupt gibt
Ich brauche Wobbly Windows, wo stelle ich Wobbly ein
Leute das wichtigste Effekt, wo ist Wobbly
Wobbly Windows endlich
Moment Leute, ah da gibt es ja richtig viel
Wobbly Windows wichtigste Sache
Eh
Wobbliness
Viel Wobbliness, extrem viel
Extrem viel Wobbliness, ich brauche Wobbliness extrem
Bester, Wobbly Windows, der einzig wahre Effekt den jeder braucht auf seinem Desktop
Früher, und es ist kein Witz, zu Zeiten von Compets und Barrel gab es noch so viel krassere Mehreffekte
Feuer wo der Desktop abbrennt und sowas
Gibt es noch den Cube zum Switchen
Ne, es gibt keinen Cube mehr zum Switchen oder
Compets war einfach geil, leider ist es nicht mehr in Entwicklung glaube
Wobbly Windows, haben wir noch was anderes, Focus, Show Desktop, Eye on Desktop
Suck Windows into the Desktop
GachiBuzz
Ganz unten
Show FPS, das finde ich gut, Apply
Boah, wenn das mal nichts ist hier
FPS Overlay auf dem Desktop, endlich, das brauche ich
This Effect is not a Benchmark
Wie wäre es, wenn man dieses blöde Anzeige unten weg machen könnte
Virtual Desktop Switching Animation, Slide, Fake Desktop
Desktop Grid
Windows Open, Close, Client, Fade
Nein, es gibt keinen, Get New Desktop
Da gibt es ein Window Effect Plugin Manager
Das ist ja mal nice
Kann man da drin auch suchen?
Fire
Ich brauche, mein Fenster muss abbrennen
Cube? Auch nicht
Ach Moment, das ist gar nichts
Das ist ja doof
Compets war einfach Poggers, absolut Poggers
Aber Wobbly Windows fühle ich mich schon mal heimischer
Früher habe ich immer Wobbly Windows verwendet
Ich war ein Wobbly Windows Enjoyer sozusagen
Ja, aber KDE fühlt sich immer noch nach KDE an
War immer noch besser benutzbar als GNOME, aber
i3 bleibt ist und bleibt das beste
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier schönes drauf?
Gibt es ein Reap Plugin wahrscheinlich nicht?
Office
Okay, es ist tatsächlich relativ minimalistisch
Obwohl, Kate, das Ding gibt es immer noch
Das ist der überladenste Texteditor, den ich je gesehen habe
Guckt euch allein mal die Settings an
Ich finde noch nicht mal die Settings in dem Ding
Ach hier, hier, Settings
Guck mal hier
Gut, im Endeffekt an Visual Studio kommt mittlerweile mehr Konfig-Sachen
So, was haben wir noch? Graphics
Development
Das finde ich gut, es ist im Prinzip nicht wirklich was dabei
Außer irgendwelche komischen Player, die keiner wirklich braucht
Oder im Movies
Channels
Da passiert einfach schon mal nichts
Einfach, einfach deadge
Aber das finde ich gut, dass nichts dabei ist
Ich persönlich bin ja ein Fan von minimalistisch
Und hier ist im Prinzip nichts dabei
Außer die jeweiligen Default-Programme für die Desktops, die wir installiert haben
Und auch nicht mal da alle
Eigentlich in Ordnung
Ja, aber ArchCompets, das haben wir ausprobiert
Das hat nicht, das hatte Probleme
Ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, wir haben es hier im Stream ausprobiert und das hatte Probleme
Es ging aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht richtig
Warum liefern sie nicht VLC? Die machen doch VLC, ist doch VLC, ist doch dabei
Eigentlich würde das reichen für alles, ne, VLC
VLC-Enjoyer hier am Start
Aber ansonsten gibt es hier nicht wirklich, wirklich was zu sehen
Das ist ziemlich rohes Standard
Recht hübsch vorkonfiguriertes
KDE
Find ich, find ich gut
Gefällt mir eigentlich
Hast du schon mal Zorin OS angeschaut, bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher
Ansonsten gibt es jetzt hier nicht viel zu sehen
Außer eben Settings in Massen-KDE
Was ist das da unten für ein Knopf?
Okay, natürlich auch schon ein bisschen komisch, wenn es auf dem Desktop etwas kaputt ist
Mit was gehen Config-Dateien zuerst auf? Kate, alles klar
Ach, die Hüpf-Animationen haben sie immer noch bei KDE
Hatten sie früher auch schon
Es fühlt sich, muss ich sagen, es fühlt sich aber durchaus ziemlich
Gerade eben auch durch die 3D-Effekte relativ responsive und gut an
Kann man sich nicht beschweren
So, nächste, was ist das?
KDE Connect
Ja, das brauche ich unbedingt
Ach, die haben auch so eine hässliche Notification-Buddy, die keiner braucht
Okay, wie lockt man sich aus?
Restart, Logout gibt es nicht, Logout ist overrated, ach hier
Sieht schon krass nach Windows 10 aus, findest du?
KDE sieht schon eine ganze Weile so aus
Es ist eigentlich immer cleaner geworden
Okay, Logout
So, was haben wir als letztes noch zu bieten?
Bevor wir i3 auswählen, wir müssen unbedingt neu installieren mit i3
Weil ihr wisst ja, ich benutze hauptsächlich ein, was heißt auch hier, ein Nur-i3
XFCE Session
Probieren wir mal SteamOS
Ja, aber nicht jetzt im Steam, nicht jetzt im Steam
Heute
Oh nee, ich brauch die Default
Nein, nein, nein
Ja
Was?
Nee, Cancel ist okay
Ich will, ich brauch Desktop-Hintergrund
Ich brauch diese Maus
Wo ist die?
Haben wir die Maus?
Das ist das beste an XFCE, der Mause-Hintergrund
Jetzt ist er weg
Schon mal andere Teile, ja, ich hab Sway ausprobiert
Aber Wayland hat mich Gatschi-Bust in Bobbes
Und es hat nicht richtig funktioniert
Ähm, ich hab mal Awesome kurz ausprobiert
Und ich glaube, es war
Irgendwas von den anderen Teilen
Irgendwas von den anderen Minimalistischen
Doch, ich weiß es gar nicht
Aber ich muss sagen, ich komm mit I3 mit Abstand
Wirklich mit riesen Abstand am Herbstlumpf
Nee, Herbstlumpf hab ich nicht ausprobiert
Das Ding heißt aber übrigens wirklich so
Q-Teil
Das hab ich
Das können wir installieren, Leute
Das haben die hier als Angebot
Wir installieren jetzt I3 und Q-Teil
Kann man das nachträglich noch installieren, Leute?
Kann man den Installer noch mal laufen lassen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Hat
Hat XFCE ein Dark-Theme?
Arkt...
Guckt euch das mal an
Massive
Okay, im Prinzip ist es XFCE, wie man es kennt
Und vielleicht mag
Mit neuer, neuer Navigationsleiste auf jeden Fall
Aber ansonsten
Es ist halt
Warum hat ein Chrome so ein komisches Icon hier?
Und warum brauche ich Adminberechtigung, um im Chrome zu starten?
Nee, brauch ich doch gar nicht
Moment, das ist doch kein Snap oder irgendwie sowas, oder?
Na, Gott sei Dank nicht
Das ist doch kein Flatpak oder sonst was
Ja, nice, glücklicherweise
Es ist richtig echtes Chrome
Schau mal Endeavor OS Tools, tja
Ja, wo?
Ich seh die hier nicht
Unter Start
Logtools gibt es, Logtools
Ah, hier kann man verschiedene Kernel-Versionen auswählen
Ja, das ist okay, das braucht man ab und zu mal
Installier mal Edge
Gibt es das? Gibt es Edge für Linux?
Ich mach mal kurz, bis sie P-Pro-Fat
Edge
Auf geht's Edge
Why not?
Es gibt PowerShell, ich weiß, ich weiß
PowerShell ist ja eigentlich ganz okay
Aber Edge
Ich weiß, wir haben hier tatsächlich ein paar Edge-Enjoyer im Chat
Manchmal schreiben hier Leute, Max, ich benutze Edge seit einer Weile und find das gut
Aber ich versteh die Daseinsberechtigung von Edge immer noch nicht
Okay, Achtung
Edge unter Linux
Microsoft Edge Def
Was will der immer mit meinem Keyring? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Okay
Das Fenster hat keine Eigens
Get started
Confirm
Lass mich in Ruhe Edge
Ja, ja, alles akzeptieren
Seriously Edge
Jetzt müssen wir noch Microsoft Advanced Thread Protection installieren, dass wir Windows Defender haben
Okay, nice
Edge, Edge unter Linux, da hat die Welt drauf gewartet jetzt
Sag mal, wie resize ich hier eigentlich Fenster?
Alt geht immer noch gescheit, okay
Weil Edge hat kein Fenster richtig
Okay, jetzt haben wir Edge installiert
Aber Leute, ich muss sagen, es gibt jetzt nicht viel, was ich mit den Standard-Desktops da groß machen könnte
Es ist okay, es ist ordentlich vorkonfiguriert
Es scheint mir relativ leichtgewichtig zu sein
Ich guck mal, die gesamte Installation hat jetzt 8G gebraucht für drei Desktop-Environments
Und ein paar Standard-Programme, das ist durchaus in Ordnung
Ich lösche mal meine Festplatte schnell, falls es überhaupt im laufenden Betrieb geht
Und dann installiere ich nochmal neu und dann installieren wir Qtile und i3
Ah ne, ich darf nicht, ich darf nicht
Aber ich weiß, wisst ihr was ich machen darf?
DD, ich kann meine Festplatte einfach DD'n, easy
Und da Partition Table über DD'n
Also DD, IF, hoch, DEF 0, OF gleich DEF SDA, Block Size 4096
Ah komm, scheiß drauf, die ersten 10 MB
Bäm, Festplatte überschrieben, nice, wie gut
Kannst du noch deinen aktuellen RAM-Verbrauch schauen, RAM-Verbrauch ist immer so eine Sache
1G, aber das ist ja immer ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zugelesen
Okay, Reboot, jetzt sollte ich eigentlich, ich müsste theoretisch nochmal sünken
Ich sollte gerade eigentlich die Festplatte kaputt gemacht haben
Ah ja, das ist eine gute Idee, Pacman minus Q und gucken was alles installiert ist
1000 Packages, aber gut, ich habe auch 3 Desktop-Environments installiert
Reboot
Endeavor OS
Count 1, ja damit er danach aufhört
Okay, jetzt E3 und Q-Teil
Also jetzt habt ihr übrigens auch mal nebenbei gesehen wie ihr einfach eine Festplatte zerstört
Also so, dass die Partitionstabelle weg ist, die Daten sind ja noch da
Sag mal, hat er sich gemerkt?
Guck mal, der hat vorhin mehr Tools im Installer, das ist mir vorhin gar nicht aufgefallen, ich kack Noob
Hab ich gerade den Installer weggeklickt
Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt wieder auf?
Welcome
Start Installer, alles klar, Online Method
Ich muss auch sagen, die Farbgebung finde ich jetzt persönlich ganz nice
Ich bin mal gespannt wie es unter E3 aussieht, also Europe, Next, German
No Dead Keys, Erase Disk, gib ihm, hau drauf
Also E3, Q-Teil, nee, gibt es nicht?
Das stand doch auf der offiziellen Seite, dass die einen Q-Teil haben, oder?
Hab ich doch hier gelesen
Ach, Community Edition
Okay, ja dann müssen wir uns jetzt E3 angucken und danach nochmal mit der Community Edition das ausprobieren
Was macht No Dead Keys?
Ja genau, das was Wout Stroning schreibt, dass so Sachen hier gleich auftauchen, ohne dass du mehrfach drücken musst
Das wäre jetzt ja vielleicht eine Distribution für mich
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, ich hab ja mein E3 selbst konfiguriert und würde dann einfach die
Wo war man denn jetzt, wo war man denn jetzt die Musik gehabt
Ich kann einfach meine Dot Files drauf ziehen und gut ist, aber trotzdem bin ich mal interessiert dran wie die E3 vorkonfiguriert haben
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die mag ich nicht
Zum Beispiel wenn man die Default Key Bindings irgendwie auf unsinnige Sachen umlegt, wo keiner mit rechnet
Neuer LevelCapture Bait, ja gucken wir uns morgen früh an
Dann können wir dieses Video morgen machen und zwar Homeoffice läuft jetzt ja aus, also die offizielle Vorgabe von unserer Regierung
Dass doch alle mal Homeoffice machen können, das läuft jetzt ja aus
Und ich bin da äußerst unglücklich drüber, also ich werde nie wieder, das kann ich ja jetzt schon sagen
Eher suche ich mir einen neuen Job, ich werde nie wieder vier Tage die Woche arbeiten mit Zugfahren nach Frankfurt
Ein Tag die Woche ist das höchste, was anderes kann ich mir nicht mehr geben
Zumal es aus meiner Sicht für alle nur Vorteile hat, wenn die Leute, die wollen Homeoffice machen
Die Leute sind fitter, du sparst ihnen den Arbeitsweg, ich mache mehr, ich bin motivierter, ich bin konzentrierter
Du erreichst auch Leute einfacher beispielsweise, wenn die Leute vor dem Rechner sitzen mit Teams
Ja und wer ins Büro will, dem will ich das ja gar nicht verbieten, der soll das ruhig machen, ist ja in Ordnung
Und bei uns ist es so, ich habe vor mindestens zwei Leuten gehört, bei einem schon relativ konkret
Dass der gerade dabei ist, sich was Neues zu suchen
Nein, ich bin wirklich fitter, also ausgeschlafen dadurch, dass ich Homeoffice mache
Ich bin aber auch tatsächlich gesünder und ausgeglichen, also gerade gesünder, also mir geht es viel besser
Seit den letzten zwei Jahren mit allem
Ich habe keinerlei Kopfweh mehr, keine Rückenschmerzen, nichts
Weniger Stress, ja, aber gut, mit weniger Rückenschmerzen liegt daran, dass ich mich mehr bewegen als früher
Aber trotzdem, es hat eigentlich nur Vorteile
Eigentlich hat es nur Vorteile, also mir fällt kein wirklicher Nachteil ein
Außer, dass manche vielleicht sagen so nach dem Motto, sie können nicht mehr taktäglich gucken, was die Leute so treiben
Aber ich denke mir halt so, wenn es die letzten zwei Jahre funktioniert hat, ohne dass der Laden pleite gegangen ist
Kann es ja nicht so schlecht sein, was die Leute gemacht haben
All done, Restart
So jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Da bin ich echt gespannt, wie die E3 umgesetzt haben
Postchamp
Okay, E3 mit einem Login Manager, das ist schon mal ganz interessant
Was ist das da? Das ist nicht richtig, richtig
Okay
Ich muss ganz schnell mal ein Terminal aufmachen
Ist es Standard? Okay, Standard Belegung für Terminal
E3 Gaps
Okay, nice, nice
Change Display Manager
Aha, Change Display Resolution
Find ich gut, dass das drin ist
Aber installieren wir erstmal die... oh
Oh, die haben das Anwendung beenden auf ein anderes Menü gelegt
Das verwirrt mich
So, VMWare, User
Das andere noch und jetzt System CTL
Enable VMWare
Oder Status
Status VMWare
Status, Status, Status VMWare
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht VMWare, VM Tools
Active
Restart
Okay
Also das Terminal ist mir ein bisschen klein, was ist das?
Das ist ein Gnome Terminal wahrscheinlich, oder?
Das ist ein Gnome Terminal
Guck mal, Source Code Pro als Standard-Font
Ist jetzt ist jetzt vielleicht nicht mein lieblings font aber kann man durchaus mit leben
Eigentlich eigentlich ganz gute wahl
Terminal finde ich okay wobei man sagen muss
Die farbwahl ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen sehr plau lastig mit den ordnern und und dann noch den blauen hintergrund oder so aber
Oh mein
Das ist aber man kann zumindest erst mal damit leben
Also ich war besser besser als ein komplettes flashbang terminal jetzt das ist wahrscheinlich
Bash gehe ich mal ganz stark von aus ja
Das ist halt original das winos achtplau ist es ne oder das winos achtplau ist ist heller
So was haben wir hier unten? Was haben die hier für eine bar unten?
Okay, sie haben mehrere
Sie haben mehrere desktops
Einen mit einem browser und einen mit einem terminal das finde ich prinzipiell eine super idee
Die sache ist bloß die ich habe es komplett anders konfiguriert bei mir ist erster desktop
Erster desktop browser zweiter desktop terminal hier ist umgedreht aber ich finde es ist nicht schlecht
vorkonfiguriert
Und man rufe wie haben sie auch am start
Sogar mit einem relativ hübschen hübschen funktionalen sie
Sieben nicht schlecht gemacht wie gesagt ich würde es nicht verwenden weil ich eben meine meine meine eigene
i3 konfig nehme aber
Das ist doch durchaus benutzbar
Was haben wir hier am start eigentlich im prinzip irefox und calculate an image viewer
In media player nitrogen ist war das das für hintergrund bilder setzen ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher ja dass das für hintergrund bilder setzen
Probieren mal edge mit video acceleration das funktioniert nicht
Weil ich bin doch in der vm das das ist doch video acceleration ist doch
Also video die coding auf der grafikkarte ist doch nur mit hardware und ganz spezielle kombination
So dann haben wir
Standard geedit oder irgendwas drauf tuner fein mannatscher
Warum auch immer man drei verschiedene terminals drauf hat keine ahnung
Ach es ist gar nicht das knoam terminal es ist das xfc terminal
Sieht aber aus wie das knoam terminal
Woher weiß ich denn jetzt das ist tatsächlich das xfc terminal
Es ist das xfc terminal
Haben wir ein funktionierendes steam. Ja mit sicherheit steam da kannst du steam installieren
Vulcan driver weiß ich ob das in meiner
Vm
So geiles
Aber machen wir mal steam drauf
Was ist denn das für ein e3 das ist das was die vorkonfiguriert ausliefern in ihrer e3
In ihrem e3 flavor das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice
Okay ist die missbar hässlich wie immer hier wenn es was das angeht
Noch mal kurz e3 konfig gucken was haben sie sonst noch für rofi bindings f noch nee
T
Für was?
Ach window filter ja gut das mache ich nie da kann man desktop switchen sowas mit das mache ich nie weil ich das nie mache
Ich weiß auf welchem desktop ich was offen habe aber ich muss sagen die konfig finde ich persönlich ganz gut und wisst ihr woran ich glaube dass das liegt ich glaube
der die entwickler verwenden das selbst
I3 ist auch mit abstand der beste desktop kann mir keiner was anderes sagen also wenn du wirklich einfach nur das system benutzen willst
als
Programmierumgebung bastel kram und sonst was und jetzt nicht wert drauf legst auf fancy wobbly windows und bling bling
I3 ist einfach das beste was du unter den jungs verwenden kannst das kommt ja das kommt ja halt einfach nicht in die quere es ist ja im
Prinzip nicht existent es sind desktops in verschiedenen fenster dem fullscreen fertig
Ja steve steve ist am start ich kann mich jetzt aber nicht einloggen
Jetbrain toolbox
Konfigurierumgebung
Ich
Gucken ob die
Java
Please aber gut das ganze chatbrains zeug ist java was willst du machen
Ja
Da toolbox
Ich will gucken ob die ein funktionierendes tray alten haben
Ok, das funktioniert so, das funktioniert, oder die haben funktionierende Tray-Icons auch
nicht schlecht, dann muss ich sagen, es ist echt, echt gut vorkonfiguriert.
Könnte ich mich jetzt nicht beschweren.
Ich würde es trotzdem nicht verwenden, weil ich meine eigene konfigure, aber ist schon
in Ordnung.
Ja, könnte ich mein Standard Entwicklungsumgebungsgedöns installieren, was ich so brauche?
Nice, nice, finde ich, finde ich gut und ansonsten halt ganz normales Archgedöns, ist wirklich
nicht schlecht.
Das würde ich tatsächlich auch empfehlen, wenn jemand sagt, irgendwie gute Distro zum
E3 einsteigen, würde ich das empfehlen, finde ich gut, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Mehr gibt es jetzt da nicht.
Also ersetzt es nicht deine Manjaro vm, wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ich damit ehrlich gesagt relativ
glücklich bin, kann keiner mehr tippen, relativ glücklich bin, erstmal nicht, aber ich finde
es auf jeden Fall eine gute Alternative, über die ich tatsächlich nachdenken werde, weil
ich die Sache mit direkten Archrepos eigentlich ganz cool finde.
Ich muss aber sagen, wahrscheinlich nimmt es sich zu Manjaro nicht so viel.
Wir können ja mal kurz in den Browser gucken, Endeavor OS vs Manjaro, was sagen die denn?
An in depth comparison, was ist an Endeavor OS besser als an Manjaro?
Ja, das fragen wir uns auch gerade.
So nah an Art Schienungs wie möglich, ja das ist das mit den Repos, was wir schon mal hatten.
Ok, das ist egal, Endeavor bietet kein grafisches Paket Shop als Fäunzel.
Was?
Ok, eigentlich ist es kein großer Unterschied, wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Ich meine, ich habe einen Manjaro Architekt, das ist halt doof, dass es es nicht mehr gibt
und den Kram selbst gemacht komplett.
Aber, ich dachte schon kurz gleich ist Monkathos hier, Alter was ist das für eine Seite, WTF?
Ok, Zack, bevor wir uns das angucken, Moment, das ist Firefox.
Warum nicht einfach Arch nehmen, das kann man auch machen.
Da muss ich sagen, ist mir der Installer hier aber lieber.
So, erstmal die Hälfte der Seite, Alter, erstmal 50 Sachen auf der Seite geplockt.
Desktop Variants, ja das haben wir ausprobiert.
ISO, Installing ISO.
Na gut, Manjaro Installation ist tatsächlich ein bisschen Panes Champ gewesen beim Architekt,
aber ansonsten ging's.
Ja, das mit den Repos scheint jetzt wirklich so das Aushängeschild zu sein, wobei es ja
eigentlich kein Feature ist, keine eigenen Repos zu haben.
Who said, das machen wir jetzt.
Das Quiz, Moment, Facebook is not your friend, it's the surveillance, das könnten beide gesagt
haben.
Also, ganz ehrlich, das könnten beide gesagt haben, ich würde aber in dem Fall tatsächlich
mal auf Linus tippen.
Fuck, irgendwie klang das mehr nach Linus, ok, Talk is cheap, show me the code, das könnte
ich auch mit Marlinus gut vorstellen, ja, wie, das war's jetzt oder was?
Programming is not a science, Programming is a, das traue ich eher ihm zu, ja, richtig,
I did write some code in Java once, but that was, das ist was von ihm, hm?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, lul, ist auch teilweise schwierig, in the real world, open source,
you have the right to control your own destiny, ja, das ist er, was, er ist doch so ein super
open source Typ, ja gut, das weiß ich, chat, das wisst ihr auch, oder?
Das ist glaube ich eines der bekanntesten, bekanntesten Quotes, ja, chat, chat, was sagt
ihr?
Die chat sagt nix, dann sag ich, ey, ist es, ich, ich, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ich war mir relativ sicher, ich war mir relativ sicher, was, wir sind aber nicht, nicht gut
gewesen, ok, wunderbar, also eigentlich macht es keinen großen Unterschied, moh, ok, der
Hintergrund hat sich ein bisschen verabschiedet gerade, aber es ist trotzdem nett vorkonfiguriert,
muss ich sagen, ich weiß, dass ich das neu auswählen muss, deswegen hab ich im Hintergrund
bei mir was, was das einmal in der Sekunde macht und neu setzt, aber, aber ganz ehrlich,
ach so, wie haben sie denn gemacht, Desktop verschieben auf Fenster angeht immer noch,
ach guck mal, die haben den anderen Desktops auch sinnvolle Eigens gegeben, hier irgendwie
der Type Browser, hier irgendwie Mail oder so, hier Instant Messenger, hier 789, ok, Desktops,
die ich alle nicht verwende, by the way, also, wie gesagt, ich hab, ich hab bei mir immer,
ich kann's ja mal, ich kann ja mal zum Vergleich, kann ja mal zum Vergleich mein, mein i3 zeigen,
wie der normalerweise aussieht.
So, also so sieht mein i3 normalerweise aus, ja, ich hab, ähm, ein Browser auf dem ersten,
äh, Terminal auf dem zweiten, ich, ich starte mal neu kurz, hier mal mal ein Update schnell,
muss ich eh machen, kam letztens wieder was, ja, kann, kann, kann gerade mal nebenbei
updaten, das ist übrigens auch was, was ich bei, äh, Arch, äh, basierten Distribution
mag, die Updates gehen relativ schnell, Q-Type machen wir hier gleich danach, äh, schaltest
du die VM nicht aus, nö, äh, die Updates gehen relativ schnell, also, das schlimmste
was Updates, also Ubuntu ist das nächste, das geht auch noch halbwegs, aber ganz schlimm
ist, ähm, zumindest früher Yam, also, also Fedora und Red Hat Updates sind richtig etzend
Pains Champ, mittlerweile mit DNF ist auch noch kacke, also ganz ehrlich System Updates
sind mir, sind mir hier und Arch basierten System am liebsten, führst dir was aus und
zack, zack, zack ist es da, der Download ist gerade ein bisschen langsam, das ist wahrscheinlich
das hauptsächliche Problem, und das flutscht einfach nur, na gut, ich lass ihn mal updaten
und dann gucken wir weiter, Q-Teil wollen wir machen, also, machen wir wieder, DD, erstmal
root, erstmal root, DD, Input, Def0, Output, Def, Str, Blocksize, 1MB, Count, 1, BAM, Festplatte
down, jetzt können wir noch mal das machen, was vorhin jemand wissen wollte, Pacman minus
Q, betippt, 845 Pakete, natürlich schon weniger, aber ich finde auch das vorkonfigurierte Rofi
und sowas, echt nicht verkehrt, gucken wir mal hier, irgendwelche anderen Tools mit am
Start, ist nice, Xfce und Alpine Linux, ja man kann sich das Leben auch schwer machen,
Neustart und jetzt Community Edition Q-Teil installieren, da bin ich mal gespannt, was
machen meine Updates, Q-Teil hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, das mach ich jetzt nur weil
jemand im Chat gesagt hat, Q-Teil POG, wie sieht denn Q-Teil eigentlich normalerweise
aus?
A hackable tiling window manager, written and configured in Python, ok dann Window Manager
in Python, ich weiß ja nicht, wahrscheinlich alles C-Module und dann sagen es ist in Python
programmiert, oh da hab ich mal gespannt, da bin ich mal gespannt, das sieht mir sehr
nach Hackermann Geschichte aus, ne das ist das falsche OS gerade, Moment Chat was ist,
da hast du recht, das gab es wohl noch nicht, als ich das mal installiert hab, ja ganz klar,
damit ich das auf meinem Desktop ausführen kann, mit Proxmox ist ja nichts auf dem Desktop
ausführen, wie soll ich Proxmox unter Windows laufen lassen, hey Max hast du eigentlich
ein paar Tipps, wie man als Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung beruflich Richtung
Linux IT Security kommt, da muss ich mich damit beschäftigen erstmal, bin momentan etwas
hard stuck auf meiner Programmierstelle mit mäßig Skills, hab mich privat jetzt viel
Spaß gemacht, du hast ja schonmal die wichtigste Voraussetzung, also die erste Hürde genommen,
weil da wird man ja nie drumherum kommen, sich privat auch mit der Sache zu beschäftigen,
ansonsten also ich kann dir jetzt bloß sagen, wie das bei mir ist, du kannst mit deinem
Chef mal drüber reden, wenn es irgendwelche monatlichen oder jährlichen Gespräche gibt,
so was man in Zukunft machen will, wenn du einen gescheiten Chef hast, kann er dir bestimmt
helfen, wie man am besten bei euch in der Firma, das ist ja immer so ein bisschen abhängig,
je nachdem was man für ein Laden ist, da am besten vorankommt, wenn du da was anderes
machen willst, ansonsten was natürlich immer geht ist, wenn es irgendwelche Projekte, Projekte
ist doofes Wort für, irgendwelche Aufgaben gibt, wo Leute gesucht werden, die in diesem
Bereich liegen, dass du dann freiwillig sagst, ja ich guck mir das mal an, ist ja nicht verkehrt
und ansonsten, ansonsten musst du konkreter sagen, was du wissen willst, also in der Regel
hat man, wenn man sich auskennt, gute Chancen in einem Bereich zu arbeiten, wo man sich auskennt
und wo man Spaß dran hat, wenn man Spaß dran hat, kennt man sich noch besser drin aus und
umso höher ist die Chance drin arbeiten zu können, ja meine Pacman-Config ist auch so
alt, da gab es noch keine parallelen Downloads, nein, nein, nein, habe ich nicht, habe ich
nicht, wenn es das geht, akademischer Bildungsgrad ist bei mir, bin ich der letzte Kacknoob,
so richtige Art Chats im Chat, ja so sieht es aus, wie macht man das in der Pacman-Config
mit den parallelen Downloads, Pacman, Conf, Parallel, nee, Down, das steht bei mir noch
nicht mal in der Conf drinne, so alt ist mein Pacman Zeug, gibt es das nicht, guck, ist
too old, too old, lass noch mal den anderen Krempel updaten, jawoll, gib ihm, schau mal
ob du eine neue Pacman Conf in einem Ordner hast, wahrscheinlich, ATC, Pacman, Pacman
Conf, Pacnew, guck mal da, ja da gibt es Parallel Downloads 5, 5 Head, nee, never change
a running system, weißt du doch, auf hier installieren, mal da oben, du benutzt Arch
by the way, ja da hast du ja für die wichtigste Hürde schonmal genommen, das wichtigste was
du prinzipiell jetzt lernen musst ist, dass du auch jedem sagst, dass du Arch Linux verwendest,
weil echte Hacker-Mans wissen das zu schätzen, und wer nicht Arch by the way verwendet, den
musst du bekehren dazu Arch zu verwenden, nur dann kommst du vorwärts, hast du mal Pacman
New Files Resolve, nö, nö, ach was, Kali Linux, wenn Kali Linux auf Arch basieren würde,
dann könnten wir da vielleicht mal drüber reden, aber es kommt als nächstes Leute mit
Tails an oder sowas, Arch Linux, einzig wahre, Blackarch, es gibt so viele Sachen, für jeden
was dabei, so, Updates sind durch, Reboot, da zeige ich euch mal kurz wie ich aktuell
meinen E3 Desktop eingerichtet habe, bevor wir das andere installieren, System D ist halt
load, ganz ehrlich, ich war, wie soll ich sagen, ich war noch nie riesen System D Befürworter,
aber ich fand das System D auch nie so beschissen, dass ich gesagt hätte, ich nehme jetzt irgendwelche
Alternativ Implementationen, die hatten doch, es gab noch eine ganze Weile, ich weiß nicht
ob es Gentoo war, irgendeine Distribution hatte doch so einen Init Gedöns noch Jahre
nach System D, also was mir halt bei System D ein bisschen abgeht, sind so Sachen wie
ETC, wie hieß das Ding, ich hab schon ganz vergessen, wie hieß das, ETC, RC Local meine
ich, genau, sowas wie RC Local, ich weiß man kann das aktivieren, aber das fand ich
ganz praktisch, du konntest einfach in ein Startscript reinreiben, was gestartet werden
soll und das wurde bei jedem Boot ausgeführt, easy, jetzt musst du irgendwelche Unit Files
machen, das ist auch nicht super kompliziert, weil es gibt Unit File Generators, du musst
dir die Syntax gar nicht merken, aber ansonsten, deswegen, wie gesagt, ich war nie riesen Fan
von System D, ich sehe aber die Vorteile, die es hat, gerade mit parallelem Ausführen
zum Starten und schnelleren Booten dadurch, aber ich hätte es auch ohne überlebt, so,
so benutze ich normalerweise mein, das ist mein normales Setup auf meinem i3, ich hab
auf dem ersten Desktop einen Browser, wenn das Ding jetzt mal startet, irgendwann mit
seinem Java krempelt, dann ist auch gut, ja ich benutze auch Bing Image of the Day, das
ist das einzige, wozu ich Bing verwende, kannst du mal dein Skript zeigen, ne, das kann ich
nicht zeigen, weil ich mir da nicht sicher bin, weil das habe ich Copy Pasted von meinem
anderen Rechner, nicht, dass ich da irgendwelche AP Keys oder sowas für Dinger drin habe,
da bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, wir können mal auf GitHub gucken, na super, jetzt
habe ich hier hin geschoben, wir können mal auf GitHub gucken, wo blorts auf GitHub, ob
ich das irgendwo in den Dot Files drinne hab, weil wenn dann, dann ist da definitiv nichts
Geheimes, hallo, Shithub, starten please, hab ich da irgendwie sowas, xinitrc, getwallpaper.sh,
ne, das ist es glaube ich nett, getwallpaper.sh ist nicht das, was in der Schleife läuft,
ey, keine Ahnung, habe ich das vielleicht gar nicht mehr in der Schleife laufen, das
muss man jetzt ausprobieren, ja gut aber theoretisch würde ich dann hier eine Schleife mit der
Kunst schreiben, tja, ne, keine Ahnung, muss man jetzt ausprobieren, Shithub, Story hat
dir gut gefallen, ist auch ein Klassiker mittlerweile, ja also so habe ich das eigentlich laufen,
das allerwichtigste, hier C-Matrix anmachen, soll ich darauf hin, ich habe auf dem ersten
Desktop meinen Browser, Fullscreen, zweiten Desktop, Terminal, Fullscreen oder Alternativ
auch, noch besser, Terminal, Fullscreen mit Custom T-Max Config, alles Fullscreen, auf
dem dritten habe ich meistens mein Frontend-Gedöns laufen, wenn ich Frontend-Zeug mache und
auf dem vierten meistens meine C-Sharp-IDE, wenn ich Backend-Zeug mache, oder irgendwie
je nachdem was, ja und dann verteile ich die anderen Programme eigentlich je nachdem, wenn
was dazu kommt über die restlichen verfügbaren Desktops, so habe ich das, so habe ich es
auf der Arbeit, so habe ich es auf der Arbeit auch, genauso, Browser, Terminal und hier
dann halt meistens irgendein Editor, ich habe es exakt so, wie ich es auch hier habe, also
kein Unterschied, so Start Installer, ach nee, Sekunde, Community Editions, soll ich mal
gucken wie viele Packages ich drauf habe, ich habe so viele unsinnigen Packages drauf
Leute, Pacman minus Q, ich schätze mal 3500, was, so viele unsinnige Sachen habe ich ja
gar nicht drauf, tja, gut so viel ist gar nicht installiert, wie hast du eigentlich die
feste Größe vom Netzwerk-Dings in den Statusbar eingestellt, das da, das ist config i3, nee,
i3-status-rs, das nennt sich i3-status-rust, gibt es auf GitHub und das ist der Standard-Block
dafür, den es gibt für Netzwerk, ich habe da gar nichts gemacht, das ist nicht die Standard-i3-Bar,
die Standard-i3-Bar ist abfuck, ok, Englisch, next, Berlin, next, German, no dead keys, Erase
disk, ok, Community Editions kommt jetzt, Sway Q-Tile, auf geht's, bin ich mal gespannt,
LTS, next, users, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, next, install, yes, das sollte
ja schnell gehen jetzt, hast du schon mal Sway ausprobiert, ja, vor, weiß ich zwei Jahren
oder so, das haben wir gestreamt, das habe ich gestreamt damals und das hat richtige
Probleme gemacht mit Wayland, könnte sein, dass es an der VM damals lag, dass die da
nicht so gut damit klar gekommen sind, das Problem war unter anderem, dass noch nicht
mal Anwendungen richtig skaliert sind, ich habe damals ein GNOME Terminal gestartet unter
Sway und habe das mal resized ein bisschen und es hat quasi nicht das Terminal resized,
sondern quasi komplett alles resized, dann ist auch die Schrift größer geworden beim
resizen und sowas, da hat quasi die Anwendung klein gelassen und einfach nur per post processing
scale filter als hoch skaliert, so richtig unusable gewesen, vielleicht ist es jetzt
viel besser, kann ich nicht sagen, Leute, ich habe jetzt neben mir Mundspray stehen,
hat mir auch mein Arzt aufgeschrieben, soll ich zweimal am Tag, zweimal mir in den Mund
spritzen und das ist dann viel besser für die Mundschleimhaut, ich habe heute morgen
eins genommen und es schmeckt, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, es schmeckt gut, aber auf
eine Art und Weise gut, wo man weiß, dass es eigentlich schon wieder nicht gut ist,
also es schmeckt so ein bisschen nach süßem Gummibärchen Kram, finde ich und nachdem
ich weiß, dass da definitiv keine süßen Gummibärchen drin sind, schmeckt es zwar
ganz gut, aber du weißt, dass es sicherlich eigentlich nicht gut ist, was genau macht
er da eigentlich gerade im contextual processing shop, installen, ok, was spritzt du dir dann
in den Mund, ich spritze mir in den Mund Stada, nicht Stadia, Stada Protect Mundspray, also
nicht hiermit zu verwechseln, das spritze ich mir in den Mund, zweimal am Tag, Gachibas,
Endeavor OS ist sehr nice, benutze ich selbst seit Monaten, hast du mal Manjaro zufälligerweise
davor benutzt und was war dein Grund zu wechseln, das wird mich wirklich interessieren, weil
ich bin halt in der gleichen Situation, du darfst Links posten, aber je nach Link kann
es sein, dass es der letzte Link ist, den du gepostet hast, aber dann musst du schon
ganz böse Links posten, hat Magenta Gaming nicht, was, Moment Magenta Gaming ist weg,
wirklich, ne, ist immer noch da, ne, das ist was anderes, das ist was anderes, ne, ne,
das ist was anderes Leute, das ist was anderes, das ist was anderes, das ist nicht der Game
Streaming Service von der Telekom, das ist was anderes, was Magenta Gaming eingestellt,
Magenta Gaming, ach wer hätte das gedacht, wer hätte das gedacht, da konntest du so Klassiker
spielen wie Asterix und Obelix 3, das war bei denen ein Topspiel, da ist es doch, da
ist es doch, das war bei denen ein Topspiel, Manjaro hält Updates zurück, ja, das ist
das einzige was ich bisher auch als Vorteil gefunden habe, dass sie direkt ihr Archrepos
verwenden, gut, anscheinend ist das wohl auch der Hauptausschlaggebende Punkt.
Ja, es ist ja auch absoluter Bullshit, wer braucht denn sowas, auf die unbefriedigende
Nachfrage, wer hätte damit nur rechnen können, das war ja komplett unvorhersehbar, dass die
Leute nicht Magenta Gaming haben wollen, ich meine Stadia ist schon dead quasi von den
Usern irgendwo, aber Magenta Gaming, wie viele User hatte das dann am Ende, 5? Die Battlefield,
ja wahrscheinlich, was sagen denn die heise Forum Leute dazu? Heise Forum ist ja immer
so eine Sache für sich. All done, Restart, Bam, so Q-Tile, das bin ich ja mal gespannt,
ich habe noch nie neben Langen in den anderen Window-Manager, in den Tiling Window-Manager
als E3 verwendet, guck mal, ob mich das überzeugt hier, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, so, ich muss erstmal
versuchen Terminal zu starten, gleicher Shortcut, gleicher Shortcut wie bei E3, das kommt mir
schon mal entgegen, momentary Installing, wait a minute, warum? System, CTL, Restart,
VM Tools, ok, ist schon drauf, ist klar, ok, also Q-Tile, was haben wir da, aha, man kann
hier oben draufklicken und es passiert was, was auch immer, das ist Rofi, aber in einem
komischen Modus, ich weiß nicht, was die mir damit sagen wollen, Firefox, jo, so und wie
switch ich desktops, so, alles klar, also wie bei E3, nur dass es sich ein bisschen träger
anfühlt, Moment, man kann die desktops track und dropen, oh jetzt habe ich sie mir schon
mal kaputt track und dropped, das ist schon wieder zu viele Features für mich hier, ok,
warum nicht, ja, in Ordnung, die haben irgendein, die haben im Hintergrund irgendein 3D Zeug
laufen, deswegen ist nämlich das überplanten, Peacom, ah Peacom läuft, ok, dachte ich mir,
was Richard crashed, stand irgendwo da, wo, habe ich gar nicht gesehen, ok, wie kriege
ich, wait a minute, wie kriege ich denn das wieder fullscreen, wie, wie kriege ich denn
das jetzt wieder fullscreen, weiß nicht, machs einfach neu auf, null, nee, Windows F ist
es nicht, das dachte ich auch, Moment, warum kann ich ein fullscreen Fenster überhaupt
verschieben, nee, mittlere Maus ist es auch nicht, der fokussiert die Fenster nicht automatisch,
das triggert mich, Fenster schließen weiß ich auch nicht, wie die Shortcuts sind, ja,
ich komm damit nicht klar, ich kenn die Shortcuts nicht, wo sieht man denn die Shortcuts, Konfig,
zum Teil, Konfig, spukige Musik, Fokuss Windows Activation, wo sind denn, wo sehe ich die
Shortcuts, wo sehe ich die Schuhe, wo finde ich, wo sehe ich meine Shortcuts, es ist ja
schön, wenn die Konfig ein normales Python Programm ist, aber so ein bisschen, wie man
sich da zurecht findet, wäre schon nicht verkehrt, Mordi, Chainlaw, ich hab das gerade aufgemacht,
warum postest du das, was soll mir das sagen, das ist nicht E3, das ist, Peace, Peace,
das ist nicht E3, Leute, sieht das aus wie E3, von der Konfig und allem, Leute, das ist
kein E3, Chat schon wieder am Schlafen hier, aha, hier kann man Keys, ok, was haben wir
denn hier für Keys, also hoch runter, guck mal, blödes E-Mode einplanen, Air ist Run-Menü,
ok, da kann man so was wie Firefox starten, ok, ich würde ja einfach nur gerne wissen,
wie ich Fenster wieder groß, der fokussiert die Fenster nicht automatisch, das triggert
mich jetzt schon, wird das super unleserlich, haben wir Vim auf, vielleicht haben wir ein
bisschen Sonntags Highlight, so, also Hintergrund vom, was ist denn das für ein Terminal überhaupt,
Zoom-Preferences, mega Paints-Champi-Default-Font, muss ich sagen, Cascadia-Code ist ganz gut,
ist Cascadia-Code nicht dieser Microsoft-Campel, ja, Opacity, Opacity muss weg, Solid Color,
aber das ist schon ein bisschen Paints-Champi hier, auch die Farbe, was denn, wie mache
ich ein Fenster, was ich verschoben habe wieder sticky, was, Control-H, nee, ah nee, Mod,
Control-H, da brauchst du ja beides dafür, L, Shift-Return, der fokussiert die Fenster
nicht, wenn man sie schließt, das halte ich nicht aus, ich bin halt so blöd für das gerade
zu bedienen, nee, Leute, ich bleib bei E3, ich bleib bei E3, fertig aus, nee Super F
ist es nicht, ich bleib bei E3, da weiß ich wenigstens was abgeht, man muss ja nicht Sachen
quasi wechseln, einfach nur des Wechsel-Villains nach, löschen, alles gelöscht, auspent und
den Papierkorb leeren, warum kein Dark Mode, ich hab Dark Mode unter Windows, ja Leute,
ich muss sagen, also die E3 Basis-Config hat mir wirklich ganz gut gefallen, weiß ich
doch nicht, Chain-Lower, wo soll ich das wissen, du fragst dir mal Sachen, also ich muss sagen,
die E3 Vorkonfiguration war ganz nice und an sich macht es echt einen ganz guten Eindruck,
also ich denke, wenn man nicht so viel Wert darauf legt, die Sachen vorkonfiguriert zu
haben, ist es auch eine gute Wahl, weil du kriegst halt ein offizielles Arch-Linux mit
offiziellen Arch-Repos und allem, was daran gut ist, ja, auch User-Repos und sonst was
finde ich nicht schlecht und ich könnte mir vorstellen, sollte ich jemals mein Daily-Arbeits-Linux
sowohl daheim als auch vielleicht auf der Arbeit neu installieren, vielleicht nehme
ich dann Endeavor OS an statt Manjaro, warum nicht, Unterschied ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
groß, ich glaube, das würde ich tatsächlich machen, ja, bei deinem Windows-Desktop, wieso,
das ist doch besser, verstehe gar nicht, was die Leute immer für Probleme haben mit meinem
Windows-Desktop, weird Champ, wer damit nicht klar kommt, warum kein Vanilla-Art, hat kein
speziellen Grund, können wir auch mal im Stream machen, können wir auch mal im Stream machen,
cringe, wer mit dem Desktop nicht klar kommt, ach ja, es gibt übrigens, wer das noch nicht
gesehen hat, weil es der Chainlord gerade schreibt, es gibt allen Ernstes ein Arch-Install-Any%-Run,
den man aber irgendwie nicht findet, Speedrun, Gentoo-Install, ach guck mal, es gibt einen
neuen Weltrekord, eine Minute 14, Arch-Linux-Install-Speedrun, mit Splitz, so man hat Fdisk gemastert hier,
der kennt sich aus, oh, time wasted, noch Zeit für den T-Max-Install, okay, ah, die Braucher,
weil er nebenbei zwei Sachen macht, Bayra das natürlich auch, das machen könnte, könnte
beispielsweise die eingebauten Konsolen verwenden, f1, f2, aber warum, T-Max-Install geht ja
schnell, richtiger Hacker-Man, der Typ, der wartet jetzt bis es oben fertig ist und Reboot
ist dann unten, was er hier unten macht ist, der installiert seinen Boot-Manager, also
unten wird der Boot-Manager installiert, möglichst oft Enter drücken, wenn er fertig ist, ganz
wichtig und time, Arch-Linux-Install, Weltrekord, eine Minute 14, nice, gibt es einen Moment
bei Speedrun, Linux-From-Scratch-Speedrun, das ist aber kein richtiger Speedrun, okay,
das ist fake, das ist fake, das ist fake, dieses Meme gibt es ja zu ganz vielen Sachen
schon, aber es passt, aber es passt dazu einfach, es passt aber irgendwie ganz gut dazu, ein
Gentoo-Speedrun gibt es auch, tatsächlich, können wir gleich gucken, Gentoo, Gentoo,
wie lange geht der Gentoo-Install, 2 Minuten 30, wobei der muss kompilieren, das dauert
länger, Alter, reg dich ab, man, es passt, es passt aber wirklich ganz gut an Zeit, dabei,
okay, mal gucken, wie lange der Gentoo-Speedrun ist, chat, was habt ihr mir da geschickt,
war das Toss, war das, okay, das muss ich mir auf dem zweiten Bildschirm nochmal angucken,
Moment, Moment, wenn das Toss war, muss ich die Aufnahme löschen und ich werde gleich
gebannen, wer mich gebadet hat, mir so einen Scheiß schickt, ach nee, das ist nicht Toss,
okay, kein Toss, kein Toss, Leute, das sieht aber auf den ersten Blick äußerst Toss-mäßig
aus hier, ich habe nur gesehen, irgendeinen Hemd irgendwie runtergezogen, ich dachte mir,
jetzt irgendwelche Titten in der Kamera und ich werde gebannt, was ist das denn, Gentoo-Speedrun
20% Colonel Skip Femboy Edition 21 Minuten, okay nee, das ist mir jetzt zu lang, Gentoo-Speedrun
tatsächlich hat es auch nicht so die geilsten Bewertungen, oh und der Bildschirm ist auch
ein bisschen am abkacken, Byte Strike, ich habe keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
ein Kerl, der seine weibliche Seite zeigt, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich blick da eh nicht
mehr durch, das ist komplett an mir, geht das an mir vorbei, ich check da gar nichts
mehr, ich bin einfach der Meinung, jeder soll das machen, was er für richtig hält
in dieser Richtung, selbst wenn einer der Meinung ist, er möchte jetzt gerne ein iPhone
sein, ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung, ich habe damit keine Schmerzen, können sie alle
machen, aber wie da, wie was richtig genannt wird, ich habe es aufgegeben, ich blick da
nicht mehr durch, da bin ich zu Boomer für, da muss Zebaro fragen, Zebaro kann ich zu
solchen Sachen hier fragen vielleicht, so Leute, wir haben noch 20 Minuten Zeit, wollen
wir noch mal gucken, was uns YouTube gebaitet, Next Battlefield, ok, das gucken wir morgen
früh, das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an, Smart Light Strips, können wir uns vielleicht auch
morgen anfangen, weiß ich schon nicht, ich mache mal ein paar Sachen auf für morgen
schon, unfinished, is incomplete, ja die Hälfte läuft nicht drauf, er wieder hier, Battlefield
Friends 2042, ja gut es gab genau eine Battlefield Friends Folge, danach hat er den Kram quasi
eingestellt, weil es niemand mehr spielt, du musst dir überlegen, was das für einen
Hype hatte, dass du gerne einfach eine animierte Serie über Battlefield 1,2 Millionen Zuschauer
hat und dann kommt das Game raus und es hat einfach nur noch, Sekunde, ho, es ging aufwärts
Leute, 100 Leute mehr als das letzte Mal, es ging rauf von 2.900 auf 3.100, die Kehrtwende
ist geschafft Leute, bald sind wir wieder oben, bei 3.200, 10 Design Patterns Explained
in 10 Minuten, das ist mir zu high IQ, gedönnt gerade, Age of Empires in der Krise, ja die
Leute rennen den Spieler weg, steht auch sogar da, vor allem liegt das daran, ich gucke ja
bei Krabi öfters mal auf Twitch, Age of Empires 4, da spielt letztes Jahr auch nicht mehr so
viel, dass sie ewig lange mit Balancing Patches brauchen und nix auf die Reihe kriegen, es
ist wieder der gleiche Scheiß wie bei jedem Multiplayer Spiel, wo du dir denkst, wie können
die Leute so ein gutes Spiel entwickeln, aber es dann im Post-Launch Support so massiv
verscheißen, ich verstehe die Welt manchmal nicht so genau, was für ein Ding, Moment was,
was passiert hier gerade, MonkaS, was zur, alles klar, ok, ok, ne da tut sich nix, ne
ich kann mir nicht angucken, da hab ich gleich schlechte Laune, Server Rack Build, was wollen
die alle mit dieser blöden Tree Machine, das verstehe ich nicht, alle, alle, also nicht
alle, aber viele, wenn du dir irgendwelche Rack Builds anguckst, die setzen sich alle
so ne komische Tree Machine ins Rack, was willst du denn da mit, ok du hast ein hübsches
Gui für die meisten Sachen, oh guck mal ich krieg mein eigenes Video empfohlen, absurde
DNS Sperren gegen Porn Seiten, gegen P-Sternchen-Rin Seiten, eigenes Video am Start, ja ich
hab rumgehustet, ist tatsächlich ein bisschen besser, was gibt es neu an der Battlefield
Front, weiß ich nicht, ich spiel den nicht mehr, gibt ja auch keinen Grund zu spielen,
guck mal der Logpacking Lawyer hat einen ESP am Start, Linux Users be like, hä?
Wo ist der, wo genau ist der jetzt der, wo ist da jetzt der Witz, ach Linux Users building
their Computer, ach so, lul, lul, not not lul, Plants vs Zombies ohne Sonnenblumen, ok
das ist genau die richtige Länge vom Video, vielleicht ist es auch nur ein Chebat Video,
übrigens wisst ihr was mich bei Plants vs Zombies immer so ein bisschen sad gemacht,
dass das Spiel nie den Nachfolger bekommen hat, den es verdient, Plants vs Zombies 2
war einfach nur Pay to Win Shit as Fuck und danach, den 3er haben sie ja glaube ich gleich
wieder eingestellt, der sah aber auch richtig lame aus, das erste Garden Warfare war erstaunlich
spaßig nochmal, ich verstehe nicht wie man das so verscheißen kann, es war ein richtig
gutes Game, man hätte eigentlich im Prinzip das gleiche nur in größer machen müssen,
nur Pay to Win Scheiße, ok gucken wir mal, muss mal kurz die Musik ausmachen, also wer
das Game nicht kennt, das ist ein Tower Defense Game und das ist quasi das was in Game, ich
nenne es mal Geld generiert, wo man dann Türme bauen kann mit, schon mal Plutonium Bad Black
Cops 2 gespielt, nee aber ich bin gespannt auf, wie heißt denn dieser neue Mod auf MW2
Engine, der jetzt irgendwann, der quasi best of Call of Duty macht, aus irgendwie 5 verschiedenen
Call of Duty alles zusammenmixed wird, der irgendwann in etwas näherer Zukunft erscheinen
soll, nicht Plutonium, sondern wie heißt denn das andere, ich weiß es nicht, SM2, SM2 genau,
ich weiß das immer, aber ich folge den auf Twitter und kriege manchmal neue Posts, kannst
du mir sagen warum ein Manjaro i3 das Mauskrollen so bescheiden annimmt, also es gibt eine Sache
die du mal, in der VM oder in echt, ja also es gibt eine Sache die du mal ausprobieren
kannst, die manchmal hilft mit Input und, ja sagen wir so VMer Tools und Zeug hast du
ja wahrscheinlich schon installiert denke ich mal, wenn nicht dann solltest du das machen,
aber eine Sache die manchmal hilft ist, wenn du, probier mal das hier aus, View Exclusive
Mode, guck ob es dann immer noch so ist und dann was du immer noch machen kannst ist,
du kannst deine Maussense höher stellen, also dass der quasi pro scrollen mehr scrollt,
das kannst du global hoch stellen, wenn das nix bringt dann weiß ich auch nicht, ich gucke
jetzt mal kurz das Video, dann ist 22 Uhr und dann kann ich dann bettengehen, ok leute
ich glaube das Video ist langweilig, ich hab so, kennt ihr das, ihr fangt ein Video an,
findet das Thema interessant, aber ihr habt den Eindruck nach 30 Sekunden, dass das Video
langweilig wird und genau diesen Eindruck habe ich jetzt auch, mal gucken was er macht
später, nur bei meinen Videos ja, ich weiß, schon schrecklich bei meinen Videos gucken
muss, Zoomer Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, richtige Zoomer Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, die dunkle Wahrheit
über Flirtbots, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das Flirtbots sind, ich dachte das sind einfach
nur dumme Spammerbots, die dumme Sachen spammen die ganze Zeit und mittlerweile die Pests sind
auf YouTube, das ist tatsächlich nicht weit weg von der Realität, wenn irgendjemand auf
die kolorreiche Idee kommt Archlinux Chrome zu installieren und nicht quasi eine Binary
Version nimmt, sondern eine zum selbst Kompilieren, was aber keiner dabei verstanden ist macht,
wie sieht das so aus, Moment, das ist einfach nur, das ist ein DD auf seine Festplatte ist
das, das ist ein DD auf seiner Festplatte will ich sagen oder, oder, oder ein random nach,
einfach random rausgekettet, was, Fireship Video ist nice, welches denn, why time sucks,
was time a programmers worst enemy, okay, drei Minuten Fireship können wir uns geben,
da macht echt gute Videos meistens.
It is March 17th 2022 and you're watching the code report.
It's about time we had a talk about time.
You would think it's a pretty simple concept.
Time began on January 1st 1970 with the eunix epic at any moment we can get the number of
milliseconds elapsed from this date on any computer using a method like date now.
This is called incremental, but one problem is that the earth doesn't rotate evenly because
it's actually flat.
And the international rotation service occasionally made it obvious, haben wir jetzt ja schon genug
in Videos gehört, dass das leap second where an additional second is added to the last
minute of the day things start getting weird when we talk about time zones, which are calculated
relative to Greenwich Mean Time, Linux Guru Talks, but in Newfoundland they only subtract
three and a half hours, Ach so, ja time, da gebe ich ihm recht, ganz ehrlich, Zeitzonen
und Time Handling ist mit das beschissenste von beschissenste, was es gibt, also ich bin
froh, dass ich noch nie an einer Date Time Library mitarbeiten musste, das ist wirklich
absoluter Abfuck, Zeitzonen und Formate und sowas und wisst ihr wo dann noch schlimmer
ist, wenn du Zeitzonen in C++ machen musst, dann ist komplett vorbei, weil dann hast du
kack Programmiersprache und kack Zeitzonen, das ist doppelt kacke, ich weiß ja nicht
ob doppelt kacke schon wieder gut ist.
Ja außer, außer, hab ich euch ja schon ein paar mal erzählt, Schweden hatte glaube ich
mal einen 30. Februar, weil Schweden vergessen hat sein Kalender umzustellen und das dann
einfach mal abgestimmt, dass die Zeitumstellung abgeschafft werden soll, oder vor vier Jahren?
Tja, die EU ist dran, die nehmen das mit für den nächsten Sprint wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ja, das hab ich schon gelesen.
Ja, JavaScript Date Handling ist wirklich eklig.
Ja, DateNow ist ein Timestamp, NewDate ist eigentlich DateNow in DateObject und ne, also
die JavaScript Time API ist wirklich eklig.
Das ist ganz gut, das verwende ich auch gerne.
Ja, JavaScript ist mittlerweile eigentlich ganz gut, mittlerweile ist das durchaus brauchbar.
So, das soll ich mir jetzt angucken, ehrlich gesagt.
Linux Guru Talks About Linux Desktop, ok, wir haben lange keine Risitas Zeug mehr angeguckt.
Der Risitas Linux Desktop.
Ach, ihr seht's nicht, Chat ist wieder, ist sich selbst im Weg.
Wie lange lang sind ihr denn da?
Und dann bin ich da und sage mir, dass du den Tag des Kaltes bestätigt hast.
Es ist gut, dass jemand mehr dich versteht, um das zu bezahlen.
Ah, gut, der, der oben ist.
Weißt du, das Wasser der Plage?
Nein, unten.
Oh, Scheiße!
Die Säcke, die du auf der Plage hast.
Das ist nicht das von der Semana Santa, das sind die Naranzen.
Und Brisita, nimm die 20 Paillen, nimm sie, und nimm sie in das Wasser.
Und erinnere dich, wo du sie nimmst, dass du morgen nach ihr gehen musst.
Und als ich nach Hause kam, war ich am Abendabend, habe ich die Säcke runtergelassen.
Ich habe sie nimmst, so wie ich sie gesehen habe.
Ich habe sie gerissen, habe ihnen einen Stift gelegt.
Ich bin in der Küche gekommen, und es war um halb Uhr.
Brisita, was hast du gemacht? Da ist der Chef.
Nimm dich, denn morgen ist es um halb Uhr.
Ich nenne dich, damit du die Paillen nimmst.
Ich nimmte mich in den Süden, um das Restaurant zu öffnen, das das Brot war.
Und der Küche nannte mich.
Brisita, komm, nimm die Paillen.
Es ist um halb Uhr, und sie sind schon hier.
Sie haben die Säcke gebrochen.
Ich habe die Säcke ausgefeinert, weil es mir keine Zeit gab, die Schanke und den Bauch zu nehmen.
Ich bin an der Plage, und es ist um halb Uhr.
Und du?
Es ist um halb Uhr, und es ist um halb Uhr.
Und ich habe sie gefunden, weil sie mir die Paillen gebrochen haben.
Ich war in der Küche, und es war um halb Uhr.
Und als ich in den Restaurant kam, hat der Küche die Paillen gebrochen.
Und ich habe die Paillen gebrochen.
Und du?
Und jetzt denn?
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
AAAAAAAAHAHAHA
HAHAHAHAHA
Okay, das war echt nicht schlecht
HAH
Das-
Schlimm ist ja, dass da immer bisschen was wahres dran ist
Das fand ich übel, ja
Läuferne Runde gekackt
Bevor wir jetzt im Bett gingehen
Schon spät
Wir machen mal wieder Automusik. Moment, das ist Remix. Ich will nicht den Remix, ich will das Original. Leute, ich geh jetzt ins Bett.
Ah, Eiser Stream. 3 Stunden 13 und mir tut der Hals gar nicht extrem weh. Eigentlich alles gut. Ich glaube es wird jetzt langsam aber sicher besser.
Nice. Jo, gibt es noch irgendwas zu sagen? Morgen früh bin ich wieder da.
Aufwachen Stream, das war ja quasi ein Schlafstream und jetzt morgen früh gibt es wieder Aufwachstream, so zur üblichen Zeit.
Fabie, Dankeschön für die gegifteten Zaps. Für 1,5 Stück. Danke, danke. Pog. Huge Pog.
Morgen ist nicht Montag, nein. Du hast Glück.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Machts gut. See you.